Oh Hello it is it's very very late So I forgot give me a sec I got disappear for a sec cuz I for poof give me a sec It's a little magic trick cuz I forgot to do something real quick Poof professional it's on twitch.
I don't need to be that Professional
Poof I'm back.
I'm ready for the crash.
All right, guys I'm gonna give do one game on the main If it's okay, so I'm gonna do one loss on the main and if the See how that goes If we lose on the first game on the main, I'm swapping accounts.
The other counts also return it It's it's eternity.
So like it's not like, okay, it's low eternity.
So like it should be fine.
It should be fine Also, Mary, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Oh wait subs.
Sorry.
I forgot subs on this channel Thank you the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
Thank you LW thank you for the twitch prom.
Thank you But yes today is for those who are wondering Why am I streaming Marvel rivals on twitch for those who don't know?
I have a partnership with Marvel rivals and with this partnership I am required to stream a certain amount of hours of rivals per month, and I'm a little bit slacking Because the last time I streamed rivals is apparently a week ago, but to be fair a lot of other stuff going around a going Going going on.
I'm sorry.
My brains not working right now.
I literally woke up an hour ago.
I Had a five hour nap Today so like I went to bed at 5 p.m.
And then I was like, I'm gonna take a small nap.
I woke up at
Woke up at 10 So actually 11 And woke up at 11.
Um, no, I woke up at 10.
I stayed in bed for an hour because I was like Why?
And Now I'm here I did a little bit of work and now I'm here and I was just like, okay, so I had time I could either do more work on my PC or I stream and I was like Well, technically streaming is working.
I do have I do have like to do the quota.
I still have a couple of I think 13 more hours.
I Gotta hit that.
I just need that much left and then we'll be fine
We are not doing 13 hours in one stream, we're still we're pacing ourselves I didn't make sure I don't just collect collect all of it at the last day.
I mean No, I've 13 hours left guys I I'm Jade.
Thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
Thank.
Oh my god.
Thank you for all the gifted subs everybody Quantum, thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
I Really appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
I really appreciate it so much for all the support fistful.
Thank you for the hundred bitties Thank you.
Thank you.
Hope the games are good today.
Also shout out to the minecraft story mode clip Yeah, that's great.
I feel like every year there's always like one clip of mine that goes out of like the vtuber sphere and into an anormous fear and Today like this year is the minecraft pig dying and like I was looking at the quote retweet I was looking at the quote tweet retweets and like the comments and stuff.
Um, it has Transcended language barriers and has hit the Spanish commute minecraft
Like Spanish minecraft like the Spanish minecraft Twitter community is talking about it now, too I was like it's actually transcended language border like language barriers because like Minecraft pig dying does not need like Does not need like a bear a barrier when it comes to language
Navi thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
Thank you his death just speaks so much to everybody No, no, thank you for the hundred bitties.
Thank you the fact I turned into like I knew it was gonna happen It just it still hit me for so I guess cuz like death was just I don't know like like how I didn't know how He was gonna die I knew I saw the clip of him dying before I played the game because that was like the whole reason why I wanted to Play the game because I saw that clip before and it was so fucking funny And I was like,
I need to play this game to go experience that moment But like the how it happened I was not expecting that and it actually like hit me and now I've and then I momentarily forgot that he would turn into a porkchop because I was like Oh my god, cuz like I fucked around and was like what if I just don't catch him and I did that and then I did Not know he was gonna die right after I did that Oh my god,
it was supposed to be a joke before it actually happened
Because I was like wait, it was just a prank
Um But yeah, like that's why that definitely hit me a lot harder than it should have Because I was not expecting it to actually happen.
I thought it was just I thought it was just you know, funny Haha moment.
Oh gee.
Thank you.
Let's hear.
What's up?
Thank you.
And yeah, thank you for the 21 biddies Thank you, honey lies.
Um, oh yeah also, um, um, I think I might have sleep apnea
So, you know how there's a I know that comes out of fucking norm out of nowhere but like, okay So like, um, I knew I knew I snore.
Okay, so like I know I snore I Didn't know how loud my snoring it was Until like, uh Until like I had like a sleepover with a friend and then she was like your snoring is like so fucking loud I was like, oh no, because my dad's snoring is really really loud.
I didn't think I inherited that from him.
So like
No Oh
Okay, I didn't tell you guys this so the reason I'm talking about sleep apnea It's cuz you know how there was that viral video of that guy doing his morning routine and like when he wakes up He has that no strip stuff that he knows that He has that no strip stuff and everything.
So oh my god Thank you for the 50
Thank you guys thank you all for the support guys, I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Anyway, so So like so there was that morning roots that viral clip of that guy doing his fucking more morning routine and everybody makes fun of it But then I saw him But the thing is the thing I took away from that morning routine is I see him do those like nose nose strips stuff I've always thought like does that actually work?
Because like um So I ordered them.
I like I actually I was like looking it up cuz I was like, oh my god Okay, wait, I snore and like I mouth breathe a lot when I sleep.
So I was like, okay Maybe maybe I should actually try one of these like those things the nose strip like that.
What do you call it?
I don't remember what they're at the actual name like this those tape the nose tape thing to like enlarge the nose hole though Fucking the nasal holes so you breathe more from your nose instead of your mouth.
So no, it's a tape Yeah, I don't even know what you're called nasal strips.
I don't know
So like hmm So like I want to try it out.
It's outside my door right now cuz I I Bought it two days like I ordered it a couple of days ago.
I still haven't picked it up and tried it yet Um, cuz I got But it's supposed to like make it so that I was looking it up I was looking it up and it's supposed to make you breathe through your nose more to prevent snoring and like I've noticed Recently,
um when I'm snoring because I know I snore I know I snore but I didn't know how loud it was until like My friend recorded me while sleeping and then she showed it to me and then she's like this is what it's like outside my door
And like this is what it's like in my room and this is what it's like outside my door I was like I didn't tell you guys this cuz I was embarrassed but now that I got Now
That I'm not gonna show you guys.
It's so embarrassing.
It's actually so embarrassing I didn't tell you guys this before because I was so embarrassed and but now that I have a cure for it potentially But it's just the audio I now that potentially have the cure for it by using the Nasal the nasal tape whatever
Okay I'm gonna test it out tonight and see if, like, well, I want... the way to know is that if my, my, so, like, recently, I've noticed, also, like, noticed that, not recently, but when I was sick during that, like, when I was sick, like, for the couple months,
for a couple months, it's got a lot worse in terms of my snoring and, like, my mouth breathing because, um, my throat has been, like, feeling really dry lately, which hasn't happened before.
I think it got worse because of my sickness because I've been sick for a while, so my throat felt, like, even more agitated, so I was like, fuck, okay, I actually might need to try this out because, like, to prevent, like, drying my throat even more from snoring.
And then, today, I had, like, these shower thoughts, but, like, in bed, and I was like, I should, what if, because I was like, what if I do have sleep apnea because, like, I was really scared because, like, I was thinking sleep apnea, from what I remember,
or, like, when I googled it, was that it, like, you breathe, you, you stop breathing.
You know?
I don't know if I have sleep apnea, I know I snore, and my snores are really loud, and so I was like, I don't know if I actually have sleep apnea, but it, like, it's, like, similar to snoring and stuff, so you know when you have, yes, so, like, um, I've never,
like, I've never woken up from my sleep before.
Um, I know I'm an incredibly heavy sleeper because, like, I've slept through multiple alarms, and, like, I don't even remember me turning my alarms off, so, like, if I have an alarm, I put my phone, like, off my bed, so, like, to wake wake me up.
So, so, like, when I wake up, I actually have to, like, grab my phone, like, get out of my bed to grab my phone to turn off my alarm, because if I don't do that, I would sleep turn off my alarm, and I have no recollection of it.
I would have no fucking recollection of me ever turning off my alarm.
So, I know I sleep really deep, and, but the thing is, um, I don't know if I actually have sleep apnea, but I got scared.
I got scared, because, um, because I'm, like, you stop breathing, and you know what happens when you stop breathing?
You lose oxygen in your brain.
So, I was, like, oh, my God, what if I'm getting more and more stupid every day?
What if I've been getting more and more stupid every day because of the lack of oxygen in my brain?
So, I got really scared.
I was, like, oh, my God, am I getting dumber?
Is that why?
So, I'm, like, I feel, like, I feel, like, I'm getting more stupid.
I feel, like, I'm getting dumber.
Is it because I'm having less oxygen in my brain?
Is that possible?
So, that's why, that's the whole thought process with why I got nasal strips, because I was, like, oh, my God, what if I'm getting more, what if I'm depriving my brain of oxygen?
I should really order this and try it out.
And it's all because of that fucking viral clip of that guy doing his morning routine.
I...
So, I had to try it out.
I was, like, I can't, I can't get worse.
I can't, I can't get worse.
Anyway, Pughead, thank you for the gifted sub to LackyOxygen.
Thank you, thank you.
Love, thank you for the hundred bitties.
No, thank you for another hundred bitties.
Cobalt, thank you for the hundred bitties.
And Pughead, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God, there's so many.
Thank you, guys.
Mighty, thank you for tier one.
Matt, uh, Tasty, and Dad, thank you for the hundred bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, not against sleep.
Nasal shifts only help against normal snoring.
Not...
Okay, so that's why, because I don't know if I actually have sleep apnea.
I know I snore, but I don't know if I'm not breathing.
That's the biggest issue.
I can't tell.
Because, like, I don't wake up from snoring.
I get, like, sleep.
I don't know if I wake up from snoring, so I don't know if I just stop breathing.
Like, I can't tell.
So, like, I'm gonna try the nasal strip to see if I feel any better.
To see if I feel any better.
And if I do, then I fix the problem.
Then I don't have sleep apnea.
Oh, I don't grind my teeth.
I don't grind it.
So, like, that's why I know I don't.
Because when I've been to the dentist, and they have never...
Every time I've been to the dentist, I've never had, like, teeth grinding issues.
So, anyway.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, we need... Oh, I have four rolls!
Let's go!
I need to get my venom shit.
Alright, let's see.
People seem to know that you... People seem to say that you would know if you had it.
I don't know.
I'm pretty stupid.
I don't know if that comes from... No.
If that came from...
The la...
It came from my brain being deprived of oxygen?
Or, like...
I can't tell.
I actually, legitimately can't tell where it's from.
So, we'll see how it goes.
I'm gonna try out the nasal strips and see if I do get better.
If I do get better, then, like, I have nothing to worry about.
Anyway, guys.
Let me warm up real quick before we... Okay, I have... I need, like, where am I?
One, two, three.
Okay, I have three more.
And then, I'll get my... What are the goals?
And then, I can get... Then, I can get my venom emote.
The fucking thing where he's twerking.
I wish that emote was universal.
I wish they gave that emote to every character.
Every male character.
Cause, you gotta admit, it looks better on the male superheroes.
Cause, I wish I could do that for, like... Cause, I saw the ones where it was only the male characters.
No, no, no.
Just the males.
Cause, I think it's funnier.
Cause, it's April Fools!
It's not Sexy Fools!
It's April Fools!
So, I feel like... When I saw it on the Hulk and Groot, I was like... I felt like it would've been so much better if it could be on all the male characters.
Cause, I wish I could have it on... I wish it was real on the Hulk and Groot.
Cause, I saw the videos of it.
And I was like, oh my god.
It's more funny on the Hulk than it was on Venom.
It's so sexy!
Okay, but could you imagine if we... If we could see a Mr. Fantastic throw it back for Sue?
Come on, think about that.
Alright, what do I need?
I need three... I technically... I need three more roles.
Okay, the Punisher.
I'll do, like, two quick plays for this.
Um, the Punisher.
I'll do the Punisher, actually.
Eh, Storm.
I can play quick play Storm.
And defeat 25.
Yeah, quick play Storm.
Um... Wait, if I do Punisher, I get both of these.
Wait, no, Storm.
Okay, if I just play Storm.
Yeah, or play Hela.
Wait, Hela... Is there another Hela one?
Hela... Hela... Hela... Okay.
No, Storm is the easy... Storm is so fucking easy.
Alright, give me a sec.
I want to see if I can... I'll do two quick plays on Storm and see if I can get it.
There are tournament matches today?
I do not care about competitive that much.
Unless the team recruits me as a mascot, I don't care.
I joked about it.
I was like, what if, like, you could just put... Apparently, um... Apparently, um, you can be put on the teams and just not do anything.
And I was like, okay, I would... I wish I could... They could just, like, put me there and just... I just received the top five thing.
Like, you know the... You know, like, the... The little banner they receive by placing, um, in the MRC?
And then they actually... Even if you didn't participate, it... Because managers get it too.
Like, from what I've seen, like, I was like, wait, this person has, like, the top four.
And I asked about it and they're like, oh, that's just, like, one of the staff members.
And I was like, you can do that?
You could just, like, not...
You know what?
You don't have to do anything at all.
And you just receive it?
Just because you're staff?
I was like, oh my god.
I wish I could have... I wish they could just put me on the team and then...
Yeah, I could be, like, the mascot, you know?
I'll watch party you.
Like, Shroud's on his team thing and he's gonna get, like, a fucking top five shit?
Like...
I mean, he funds the team, but, like, I could just watch it.
I could watch it.
Like, watch the matches.
Man, is that not enough?
Oh my god, so demanding.
Is that not enough?
Watching is not...
He's Shroud.
Yeah, I'm the Shroud of Vtubers.
I could be the Shroud of Vtubers.
You don't know that.
If they put me on the team, I will become the Shroud of Vtubers.
Obviously, like, I don't want to go up.
I should go up because I did that.
There we go.
One.
I got one, guys.
Here we go.
Come on, give me that two.
That's great.
Two.
Three.
I need my April Fool's emote.
V Shroud.
Are you gonna pay, like, Shroud?
Alright, guys, if I ever get a multi-million dollar deal, I will make my own Vtuber...
I'll make my own Rivals team.
If I ever get a fucking multi-million dollar deal, guys.
That's the dream right there.
I'll turn all these pro players into Vtubers and then, like, create my Rivals team.
I'll be called... what's his name?
This was Shroud X, right?
Jokey X.
Just fuck you in particular.
I need that kill.
Alright.
Hello, he's healing me.
Oh my...
Okay, I deserve that.
Okay,
that was my bad.
That was my bad.
Alright, five out of twenty.
That's okay.
We're almost there.
We need twenty more.
Yeah, that happens to Shroud too.
You think he's fucking invincible?
He's not invulnerable, guys.
He can bleed.
He's not perfect.
That's why he's Shroud.
Can we get closer, please?
Like, what am I supposed to do?
How am I gonna supposed to get my Venom Twerk emote if you're not closer?
Please, I'm playing quick play just for the... I'm gonna kill this Punisher.
I know you're here.
Okay, okay, I knew he was here, but I didn't know he was there.
Okay, okay, he knew that I knew apparently.
That's unfortunate.
He knew that I knew that he knew.
That's so fucked up.
How did he know?
That I knew that he knew.
That's so messed up.
How the fuck am I?
Please.
I need twenty more.
You're right.
I'm not aiming right now because of my sleep apnea because of the lack of oxygen in my brain at the moment.
That should be my perfect excuse.
Like, I'm sorry.
I have sleep apnea.
Um, I'm diagnosed by the way.
I have undiagnosed sleep apnea.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, use this to live.
Please.
There we go.
Nice.
I don't think I'm gonna get healed, but guys, by the way, I have no descend key.
I have to look down.
I don't have my descend key bounded.
I actually have to look down.
There we go.
Okay.
All right.
My descend key is on my I need healing because I think that is um, that is much more important.
That is much more important than anything else.
All right.
It's the ping was so 20 20.
It's the lack of oxygen.
It's true.
It could be true.
It's undiagnosed.
But it could be true.
It's a possibility, you know, it's all about the possibility.
Okay, nice.
Do they have triple tank?
No, they had four tanks.
How is four tanks gonna do anything for you?
You have you have one raccoon.
Okay, nice.
Oh no, I need nine more.
Oh my god, you guys were supposed to cap this so I can get my fucking venom twerk.
Kill him, kill him, please, please, no!
When it's convenient.
All right, nice.
Yeah!
No!
I need 10.
I need like 10 more.
They were supposed to fucking push through!
Please!
Okay, I need, okay, I need more.
Okay, I need less and then thank fucking god.
All right.
The next one I'll get it.
Strange out there you live.
Uh, cannon, thank you for the twitch prime.
Thank you.
Uh, rose, thank you for the twitch prime.
Peace.
Thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you.
You're so cool, bro.
I mean, I didn't watch Annoying Bell until the vtuber wars, but you're funny and you have amazing energy.
Keep it up.
Oh, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I'm glad you enjoyed my content.
Thank you, it's the lack of oxygen in the brain.
I appreciate it.
You know, you know, it's like those hats where it's like, um, sorry, I'm blank.
Uh, I suffer from blank or something.
Sorry.
I self-diagnosed myself with sleep apnea and I think I have, I think I'm depriving my brain of oxygen.
Please be patient.
I am oxygen deprived.
That's me.
Someone make me a hat.
I'll wear it.
I'll wear it on stream.
All right.
Sorry for those who are watching at four in the morning.
I took like a five hour nap and here I am.
I was gonna do this like earlier, but then but then I decided to deprive my brain of more oxygen today.
Please be patient.
I'm a vtuber.
All right, here we go.
Please, I mean, like how- you're not hiding.
You're so big.
You're literally the thing.
Like, what did you expect?
Oh, that's unfortunate to the group.
That's very unfortunate, but I'm saying like, where are you hiding from?
I forgot I was on speed.
Whoops.
Attentional, of course.
Where did they go?
Okay, that's one.
Don't worry, that's two more.
We're almost there.
Get over here.
I'm gonna kill you too.
I need one more.
There you go.
Don't- oh, you think you're gonna run?
Jeff, you think- oh, he is.
He's aiming.
He's- wait, you kidding me?
Okay, not aiming anymore.
There we go.
Okay, he's getting healed.
That's not fair, but the raccoon's not getting healed.
Wait.
Something- oh shit.
Okay, that's shooting me.
I was like, what's hitting me right now?
Okay, let me sit here on the cart.
I can just farm this here.
I can just do this.
I'll just shoot on the cart and then- Oh!
Okay.
I knew it.
I was like, I knew it.
I should have stayed in the air.
Oh my god, it's okay.
We won it.
Am I on speed or- no, I'm on speed.
I start on speed.
Guys, this is how long I have not played Storm.
Alright, guys, it's okay.
They- it's okay.
I was just bait for my team, as always.
Oh my god, we're gonna take- it's okay.
For the Venom twerking mode.
Do it for him.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm gonna kill just the Raccoon.
Um, why is he still alive?
Oh, thank god I'm in the air.
Also, but why am I- why was he still alive?
Who the fuck was I hitting?
Okay.
Oh no, where's that?
Where's that?
I can't tell where that is.
Where is he?
I- I did damage to him.
Apparently, I did damage.
Where the fuck was he?
Okay, get in faster.
Where the fuck did he go?
Oh wait, that's not- I don't have to send he.
I need to remember that.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Okay, nice.
Back to speed, I go.
Let me stay in the air.
They can't hit me if I'm in the air.
Nice.
All right, I'm doing it.
Oh, I made it.
I did it.
I could leave right now.
Oh, wait.
No, you can't.
Apparently, I found out you can't just leave after you got your achievement.
You actually have to stay.
Like, I have to stay and not fuck over my team?
That's so fucked up.
I'm only here for achievements.
Okay, you know what?
Fuck this one guy in particular.
I'm coming for you.
Wait, wait, what the fuck?
Oh, I- I'm coming.
Can't run away.
That going invisible is gonna save you.
Oh shit.
Goodbye.
Okay, it did save him.
It did save him.
All right, it's all right.
We're back.
All right, I'm back.
There we go.
Yeah, we're winning and I'll do it again.
Put you on a fucking sandwich.
All right, I did my job.
I can just sit here.
I don't have to try anymore.
That should be three, right?
That should be like, three points.
Like, enough for three rolls.
Oh shit.
No!
How high do I have to go to get the spawn?
Wait, he doesn't know I can fly.
He doesn't know we can all fly.
Fucking stupid.
He could have went to spawn and killed us.
Stupid.
Even when I'm oxygen deprived, I know that.
He literally got Thor in me.
He threw him in me.
Like, how did he die?
SillyBishop jumped off.
Yeah, I was like, what?
Oh shit, I did.
Yay!
Most damage with one final hit.
Let's go.
That was a team player.
Yeah, okay.
All right.
Oh, that's a lot.
Wait, that's actually a lot.
Wait, do I got it?
I almost got 1500 damage.
Oh, okay.
Let's see how much, how many rolls I got from that.
Oh my god, is that it?
Is that it?
Wait, what?
Why did it say zero?
What?
Wait, what?
Why did it say, why did it say zero?
What?
Oh my god, I forgot it's orbs.
I forgot it's orbs.
I was looking at the currency.
I was looking at the fucking currency.
I was like, yay!
It's purple!
I didn't realize they're not the same purple.
God fucking, okay.
Not, guys, it was not the same purple, guys.
Okay.
I need 1500 damage on, on, on Storm.
And then, okay, that's two more.
Okay, we got, that's two.
Okay.
No, it did not, see?
That's, this unlocked already.
So if I do this, I get these right away.
That's my oxygen deprived.
Oh shit, they were both purple!
I'm going with color!
I go with color, not shape.
Why didn't they change the orb to another color?
Okay, wait, but did I not defeat 25?
How do I defeat another 20?
Okay.
Well, we got this.
Oh, it just unlocked.
I literally unlocked the 15 kills as it unlocked the moment I played the second game.
Okay.
We got this.
Okay, one more quick play.
One more quick play on Storm.
This is okay.
This time, this time we'll unlock it.
Where are the other ones?
Were the other ones any fun?
What the fuck?
Did we lose?
What happened?
Did I win?
Good game, guys.
I just got here!
What the fuck?
I'm not even part of the team?
I'm not even part of the- what?
I wasn't even there.
I didn't even get to be part of this team.
Like, I can't believe Zoe is here.
Bro thinks she's on the team.
Why put me there?
I can't even be part of the team.
I didn't even get a photo.
That's so fucked up.
Okay.
Okay, now.
Now it should be fine.
Can't believe I didn't even get a fucking photo.
Like, I was like, did I win?
Did I do it?
All right, here we go.
All right.
How do you stop sleep apnea?
Anyway.
Am I fucked?
Is this why I'm like this?
No, but like, I've been like this since birth.
So maybe my body has trained itself.
For the lack of oxygen.
You cannot?
So like...
Do I just stop?
Like, does my- can my brain adapt?
Can my brain adapt to it?
Like...
The doking just evolved.
Oh my god, maybe I used to be smarter.
Maybe I was so fucking smart that like...
It's like I used to be so smart.
That like the last- so I'm just losing.
I'm just becoming more and more like, you know.
Like I'm not that stupid, right?
I'm not.
Like I just, you know, I'm more stupid because I used to be so- like I used to be like a child prodigy or whatever.
And then it's just I'm becoming more.
I'm just becoming more average.
Is that it?
Yes, you are.
Like I just have so much brain cells to spare.
So it should be fine, right?
Right?
Is that stupid?
Like...
Checks out.
Got a hat to nerf doki.
All right, at least my aim is still there.
Like despite me losing brain cells, I can still aim, I think.
Yeah, I could have been like- I could have been the one that um...
I could have been the one that finds the cure for cancer, but instead I had to use that because I was- I got scared.
I got scared, but it's okay.
I get rezzed.
It's not okay because I don't know- oh, it is still okay.
Oh, fuck.
There you go.
Don't worry.
I'm a hero.
I'm a fucking hero.
Do not worry.
I'm still a hero.
Where's the- oh, there you go.
That should be 20, right?
Oh shit, okay.
I'm not- I think I'm gonna die.
Don't worry, I did it.
I did my job.
Oh shit.
Oh, that was good.
That was actually good from the spider-man, but he's dead.
But that's okay.
Well, someone's got touch card, right?
Come on, invisible woman.
Touch card.
Don't be a pussy.
But yeah, I could have been the one that like finds the cure for cancer, but then I was born with sleep apnea.
So now I'm here become- so now I'm a vtuber.
Like, just- just life things.
Okay.
I mean, it could be.
You don't know that.
My potential is unlimited.
Okay, I used that instantly because I just didn't want to die.
And also, fuck that one guy in particular.
I'm gonna die, but like, I got my kill.
Oh, I'm not gonna die.
Nice.
Wait.
Oh, I didn't see this guy.
His existence means nothing to me.
Okay, nice.
Let me get on damage.
Not nice.
All right.
Yeah, I could have cured sleep apnea, but not for sleep apnea.
It's just life things.
Okay, do I have it?
Oh, I have it.
I hit my quota.
I should be able to afford twerking emote.
All right.
You probably make people beg for it.
I'll do that thing where- I'll do something worse.
I'll work for a pharmaceutical company.
No!
I'll just slowly walk away.
The fuck?
Oh, he killed somebody.
I was gonna be like, what's he gonna do?
Fucking float to me?
Okay, I got the thunder strike though.
Okay, I'm- can somebody heal me?
I got rid of my descend key for this.
Oh my god, I'll slowly walk up.
Oh.
Oh, he gets healed?
That's cheating!
If he's gonna get healed, I should get healed too.
Oh, I did.
Okay, it's not cheating anymore.
Where are they?
I like can't see shit right now.
Oh, fuck.
I thought I got away with it.
Just float away.
Big pharma strikes again.
No, I'd work not just any pharmaceutical company.
I'd work for an American pharmaceutical company.
I'll sell the cure to America.
God, no.
Thank god you guys got saved by my lack of brain cells.
By my brain being deprived of oxygen.
Thank fucking god.
No!
If we lose, then it's okay.
Okay, that- that was a choice.
That was a choice from my strain.
At this point, it'll go.
Oh, back home.
Then I'm gonna go back.
Woo!
Huge ult.
Whoa.
Hey, that's a good attempt though.
Good for you.
You tried.
Oh wait, he gets away?
He can do that?
Not for him though.
Oh shit.
Okay, they don't see me when I'm in the air this high up.
So I don't get aimed at.
What?
Oh.
You try.
And that's all that matters.
You know what?
I'll use it here.
I know like, I know I should- oh wait, no.
I can use it.
Fuck this guy in particular.
You have no- god damn it.
How did he get healed?
It's not fair!
Get rezzed.
Nice.
I believe it.
How dare he use his teammates?
Not fair.
All right, that should be enough, right?
That should be enough for Venom.
Look at all this damage I'm farming!
Like, there's no way!
All I do is just shoot!
How does no one else have more than five kil- oh wait, no.
Our fucking support, at least they're doing something.
I'm surprised I have just as many kills.
I was like, how the fuck do I have the most kills?
How the fuck does our sup- oh fuck, I need- I need to look down.
Okay.
Oh my god, you fucking whore.
All you have to do is left click.
There's a reason why everybody avoids you in Blink.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
My fucking Sue has more kills than me.
And it's- I'm sad.
I thought I was so safe.
Okay, she's gonna be extra fucked when I actually play- if I play Hela, she's fucked.
I'll play Hela after this.
Dang.
Oh, you're stupid.
Oh, no, it's fine.
Can't believe it.
How can my support do that?
Oh, wait, wait, that's huge!
Oh my god, god damn it.
I should have chose something that was easier to kill.
I did not see the rocket at all.
No, I can't change as Hela.
I can't change- wait for me again!
Yes, okay.
Okay, not okay.
Not okay.
I'm okay.
Idiot.
This is real firepower!
Actual stupid.
Stupid.
That's right.
With the power of electricity, I shall kill this tree.
If I can see him.
That's good.
Okay, I can finally swap Hela.
Now I'm mad.
Now I'm fucking mad.
Watch as I miss every shot.
Okay.
No more, Mr. Nice Guy.
Now I'm mad.
Where's this Scarlet?
So bad.
Fuck you guys.
Fucking right- oh, now you guys can't do anything!
Whoa!
Wow!
Like I can't aim!
That's so cute, right?
Pissed me off too hard.
Don't make me mad.
I'll swap to Hela.
Quantum, thank you for the- give the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Armory, thank you for a thousand bitties.
I know you don't usually stream on Twitch only on YouTube.
Do you have any plan to update the Twitch badges of the- No, I like my Twitch badges.
You know what they are?
It's me drawing it- Redrawing the default Twitch badges on MS Paint and then snipping it, screenshotting it, and then snipping it on with my uh, snip tool and then uploading it.
So some of them you can actually see my cursor.
Uh- You can actually see my cursor on the sub badges and they're like the OG Twitch badges, so I'm never gonna change it.
I drew them!
Do you not like it?
It's my beautiful art.
Oh my god, two rolls.
I can't believe it.
I need one more.
I actually need one more!
I have- Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's fine, that's fine, that's totally fine.
Namus, thank you for the gift itself!
Thank you, thank you!
Please, I'm supposed to play ranked.
Guys, okay.
I just need one more and then we're done with quick play.
Okay, what do we need?
What do we need left?
Okay.
We need...
Okay, we need...
Oh my god, we were actually 10,000 damage away.
Okay, I can just play Hella.
I can just- Just play.
I can farm that on Hella so fast.
All right.
That's fine.
Just one more, guys.
Just one more and then we're free.
That's all we need.
Uh, Silver, thank you for the 100 bitties!
Thank you, thank you!
All right, it's Hella time.
I'm just gonna ruin their quick play game.
Give me a sec.
I'm just gonna ruin this for them.
Anyone that plays Hella in quick play is not here to have fun.
They're just here to fucking feel good.
They just- they can't feel good in ranked so they feel good in quick play.
Anyone that plays Hella doesn't have fun.
Oh, yeah.
I'm- guys, I'm doing this for the Venom twerk emote, guys.
It's all- look, it's not- it's not you.
It's Venom.
I'm trying to remember where people go from watching the streams.
I don't know where people fucking position themselves.
For this.
I don't- I like- DPS players are playing an entire other game compared to supports and tanks.
They are like- I- whenever I see like DPS streams, they're like in the whole world.
They like flank.
They actually know what's breakable and like where to- like where they're going and everything and I'm like, where are they?
I've never seen this part of the town before.
Like, oh my god, that is a new area that I've never seen.
I get so- Please, I'm just Hella.
Hahaha.
Oh, what the fuck?
They just let them do that to me?
They just let them do that?
No, I know they show but like I don't have to care about it as a support player.
Oh my god, sorry.
I looked up accidentally.
I don't have to care about it as a support player.
Because I'm just mostly- I'm not flanking or anything unless I'm playing- like most supports don't need to flank.
Like, where is it breakable?
It's been so long since I've broken stuff that I- oh, that's not what I wanted, but that's fine.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Oh no!
Oh!
Please!
He's just slowly punching towards me.
Somebody stop him!
Oh my god, somebody stop him.
He's just slowly walking towards me.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, they're still fighting.
Okay, I was- okay, never mind.
I was not planning on coming back.
I just need a damage burn.
That's all I need.
Oh my god, where do people fucking position themselves here?
I hate Iron Fist so much.
Goodbye.
If he doesn't see me, he won't kill me.
That's my plan.
Oh my god.
Oh, hey guys.
Hello.
Whoa, hello.
Saw the spider man, I was like, please.
Oh, fuck off.
You're trash.
I can farm this though.
Oh, I can still farm this.
It's okay.
I'll wait until the cloak ult is done and then let's go.
Yum, yummy.
Oh, my ult is useless.
Yes, I have- Yes, my ult is useless.
It's okay.
Where is he?
Oh my god.
Did I just even kill the team he gobbled up?
Oh my god, he could have actually just threw it in my- in my face and then I could have killed him.
Oh my god, why did you not kill them?
What was the point, Jeff?
Oh my god.
It's okay, he's still dead.
It's fine, I did my job.
Wait, does Jeff have zero kills?
How do you have zero kills as Jeff?
It's okay, he's just a little special.
Thank you, my little farmer.
Groot, please farm for me more.
Here you go.
I take this.
Oh, he's coming over.
Please kill the Punisher, not me.
Okay.
Okay, I don't want to be there.
That's fine.
Oh, that's not fine.
It's all right, I'm doing my job.
Okay.
Okay, I believe on my team.
I believe in my zero kill Jeff.
He's gonna make it, guys.
He's learning.
That's what quick play is for.
And I'm just here to farm.
Oh, he didn't hit that?
God, I don't understand sometimes.
Why did I not hit that?
Oh, what is the fucking range for that?
Okay, that's fine.
My team is healing me.
You know what?
Fuck these guys.
All right.
Okay, never mind.
Okay, I guess... I guess they all just... yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
That is not fine.
That is not fine!
Okay.
The door, um, closed.
Uh...
The door closed.
It ended up not being fine.
Why is it there?
Guys...
I do not control the door, unfortunately.
It was not fine in the end.
It's okay.
We can hold four minutes or we just...
It would be so funny if, um, I just stopped shooting here.
Because I got my points.
I hate this map the most because of this.
This, when it changes, is so annoying.
That Spider-Man has all...
Whoop.
Bye, Spider-Man.
See, look.
Oh, I hate that.
I hate this.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
I don't know where I am.
Whenever that happens, I just lose track of everything.
Oh, I... Wait, she lives?
God damn it.
I don't want a front line.
I'm just a hella... like, I... my body is so weak.
I don't want to front line this.
I have such a weak body.
Oh, hey, Invisible Woman.
Hey, you just want to watch?
That's fine.
I...
You're still watching?
You didn't even get a kill out of that.
How do you...
How do you still...
How do you still... Oh, wait, at least I finally got a kill.
I'm proud of you.
I... I'm proud...
She could have literally helped.
She did not have to stay invisible.
She just stood there.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Holy shit.
You're still...
Oh my god.
It didn't even work the first time.
It's not gonna work again.
Oh my god.
It still didn't work.
This fucker saves it just for me.
I...
Cause I'm the only one with an ult that actually means anything to my team.
Okay.
Oh my god!
What the f...
There we go.
How did he still follow me?
Your team...
The team's only tank.
Why?
Why are you still following me?
Tank for your team!
Jesus.
He wanted to kill me obviously.
How are you still there?
Is he gonna...
Is that breakable?
It's gonna fucking bash into that wall?
Like next to me?
Okay.
Yoink.
Stealing that kill.
Oh, I had to reload.
If I didn't have to reload, I might've been...
I hate aiming down though.
I'm so bad at aiming down.
Okay, that's embarrassing.
For you.
Oh my god, please.
What?
I'm sorry I can't aim anyway!
It's so hard to aim after that.
Oh my god, I can't.
I got so...
I got confused.
Like, what?
I died meditating.
I couldn't aim.
I was like, so confused.
I was like, why?
Thank you.
Why?
I'm so confused.
Oh yeah, by the way, I'm trying raw input for the first time.
I don't know if it's gonna help.
So like, I feel...
I don't know.
I've never used raw input before.
Apparently it's slower?
From what I've heard?
Okay.
Yeah, I got this out.
Alright, watch the cloak ult.
I die right out too because I have no HP.
There we go.
This guy literally does not use cloak ult until I...
I'm dead here.
Until I appear.
What's raw input?
Raw input, it uses your exact movement on your mouse.
But I've never done it before.
I've never used raw input before.
It's actually my first time.
Like, today.
I don't know if it's actually good or not for me.
I have no idea.
That's not fair.
Wait, they're healing each other.
Wait, that's not fair.
They're actually healing.
I did so much.
I did so much, but that's okay.
Hey, that's illegal.
Apparently, it makes it so your mouse movement is a bit slower with raw input.
But yeah, it bypasses...
Yeah, that's right.
The bypasses the software that controls the mouse.
Thank god, I'm so tired of LOS.
Was I doing that much?
Oh, I dealt the most damage in game.
I was like, was I actually doing anything?
I was just fucking around.
Okay.
Let's see.
Yay!
Finally, I get to move my one square.
Let's go.
When do I claim it?
When do I get it?
Oh, when does it show up?
Does it show up on April Fool's?
Oh, tomorrow?
Oh, in 14 hours.
Nice.
Oh, is it this?
Oh my god, it's this.
Okay, I did it.
Alright, now we get to play a one-rank game.
Now...
Alright.
If we lose on the main, I'm swapping accounts.
I'm moving accounts.
Yeah.
I gave myself...
Oh my god.
I worked so hard getting that turkey emote.
Let me reward myself by playing rank.
The biggest reward of the night.
Nerdy, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, long time follower.
I remember your Overwatch and emo streams.
I currently see how far you're coming in your journey.
I hope you can continue to have fun and streaming for many more seasons to come.
Thank you, Dyno.
Oh my god.
That's an OG OG Bark night right there.
Thank you so much.
I can't believe you're supporting me even now.
Thank you, I really appreciate it.
Alright, let's see.
Did we just practice in Doom?
I forgot, like, at these hours the queue times...
I don't even know if anybody...
Who's like...
Who's even on right now?
Like...
Oh, the usual ELO terrorists they're on.
Okay.
And the actual players.
There's not a lot of actual players on at this time, unfortunately.
Yeah, I rewarded myself by playing Psylocke.
Yeah, I get it on April Fool's.
I don't know.
I think tomorrow I might just...
Depending on how much...
How many hours I stream today Get over here.
Wait, what?
Okay.
I was like...
Wait, there's two of you?
I was like, wait, there's two of you?
Oh.
Oh my god, he's RPing NPC.
Oh, whoops, sorry.
I forgot about my right click.
I...
I forgot I gave you my right click there.
Oh my god, it's an actual NPC.
LRP.
It was an accident!
I forgot my right click was in his body!
I literally looked away and then he just died.
What I was saying before...
Oh, I'm in game.
What was I saying before I accidentally killed him?
I was just trying to warm up!
I don't know what the ELO is for this.
Oh yeah, depending on how long I stream today and see if I want to finish my quota tomorrow.
Jesus Christ, how do we Oh, this is gonna be a fast one game on the main I guess.
I'm not hopeful anymore.
Oh boy.
The ELO terrorists are out today.
It is 2.30 in the morning.
I'm on central coast right now too.
I think that's central.
Why did we ban?
Ban Groot!
Please!
Wait, did somebody ban?
Please, I do not want to play against Groot.
Did this guy ban Iron Fist?
Did this guy actually ban Iron Fist?
What the fuck is wrong with my team?
What?
Oh, the enemy did.
Okay.
It's always someone who doesn't hide a name.
Oh!
I was like, what?
Oh no, yeah, the enemy.
Okay, this is looking great, guys.
Oh!
Are people really trying that hard?
What?
They look up the names of like the people on our team to see what they play.
That is so cringe.
That's actually so fucking cringe.
They actually look up the names.
Yeah, there's apparently if not everybody doesn't use streamer mode.
What's the point of having competitive mode on?
I would if everyone wasn't.
It's alright, guys.
I can do this on my own.
That's so dumb.
Like, what's the point of having competitive mode if it takes just one person not being in competitive mode for it?
I don't know.
There's three fuck- there's two flankers and one guy that flies.
I don't know who the fuck to put my orb on.
I don't know who to put my orb on for this.
Guess I should have picked Spiderman who's there first.
I'll put it on Spiderman.
Oh my god.
I should have warmed up on Luna.
I 100% should have warmed up on Luna.
Oh my god.
My- I forgot how fast-paced.
Like, after playing, uh, Hella and, uh- Oh my god, it's so fast-paced playing as Luna compared to- compared to this.
I forgot what that's like.
Oh my god, my eyes are like not ready.
My eyes- no, because I was playing playing Hella and Storm is a lot slower paced than playing Luna because I don't have to be aware as aware but I have to be so aware when I'm on Luna.
Somebody save Greg!
I mean, I don't play Hulk and I'm not hopping on it.
I'm sorry, man.
Greg!
Don't worry, Greg!
No!
Okay.
Alright, everything is fine.
I need to reload.
Oh!
That froze somebody.
I- where am I?
Oh!
There's a Namor right behind me!
Guys, I don't think this game's gonna go well.
I don't believe- I wanna believe but it's hard to believe right now.
You- okay you- okay, I'll speak.
I don't know.
I don't even wanna speak if this game isn't winnable.
I don't know if I wanna speak and let them know I exist.
It is.
But it's eternity at 2 in the morning or 4 in the morning for- I don't think I can.
Okay.
Oh, goodbye, Greg.
Hello, Greg.
I don't believe in us, Greg.
Greg, I don't know if I- if enough- if enough freezes will save us, Greg.
Okay.
Let's go.
I'm going forward.
Whoa!
Don't worry, I'll die here for us.
Alright.
Yeah.
This ain't looking so hot.
Greg!
I don't even know who JellyPeanut is but look at my team.
Look at-
Look at my team.
It was- It was done by HeroSelect.
We were fucked over by HeroSelect.
We literally started off with Iron Fi- We started off with Storm, Spider, and Black Panther with a solo tank hulk.
So...
Yeah.
Whoa!
Uh...
No, he was gonna switch to invis but you took shrine so I couldn't swap off of it.
Um...
Yeah!
This...
This team is going great, guys.
There you go.
I don't know, I freeze him every time.
I don't know what more I can do.
Oh hey!
Hey guys!
Wait!
Maybe you can- There is hope in this dark world!
Oh my god!
Wait!
No, I shouldn't start hoping.
Then my hopes will be crushed.
I shouldn't.
Maybe like...
You know, it's just a false sense of security.
You know, maybe it's just bait, guys.
Guys...
Just be bait.
We can't- We can't think that there is real joy in this world.
There's no such- That's impossible.
I stopped feeling joy since I started playing competitive.
What the fuck is he- Okay.
I was like- I was like, what is that spider-man doing just waiting?
Wait.
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Whoa!
I'm ready to put on a show!
Hey, that's good.
I didn't use that for nothing.
I did that to save my own life.
But like, that's good.
That's great.
Okay.
That's fine.
I have this.
I still have this.
And then my invis woman has ult, right?
Yeah, there we go.
See, guys?
My ult- Actually, it wasn't- My ult baited out the Luna ult, so like, it was great in the end.
It was planned.
I was the ult baiter.
That was my entire intention.
How?
What is this shit?
Our spider-man was like, I give up.
How did he crash out?
He dies and then he's like, fuck this.
Please.
Please!
How could you do this?
I freeze him every time!
I don't understand!
I freeze him every time and you still let me die?
What's the point?
What's the point of doing my job?
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Portal time.
Okay.
But I'm the spider-man.
Go, Greg!
Okay, this is my first miss, guys.
Like, it's literally my first time I missed.
Running spider-man to Namor is actually like, masochist right there.
Okay, cool.
Why did no one come in there with me and Greg?
Does no one like us?
Does no one like me and Greg?
But then me and Greg...
Ew!
I went in the portal with Greg!
I believed in him!
Oh, no.
He was so fast.
I couldn't get to him.
I couldn't put my orb on him.
I swear to god.
He like, runs away now.
He's so scared.
Why?
Greg!
Why, Greg?
Why?
Greg!
Why, Greg?
Why did he ult out of nowhere?
Guys, see?
This is why I stopped being...
I stopped believing it these days.
Never trust anyone.
Not even your team.
I didn't ult that because I felt we have one more contest.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
We just...
That's totally fine.
That's fine.
I thought I was gonna ult first.
Okay, wait.
Do we have strange?
I'm gonna do a gamer move.
Wait, actually, I don't.
That's so sad.
We double support ulted.
I ulted first, too.
I did not hear that he was gonna ult.
Wow!
I did not hear the comm that he was gonna ult first.
I'm gonna say.
I don't know.
Maybe I didn't hear it, but I definitely...
He was not loud.
I did not hear that he was gonna ult first.
I heard zero comms from that guy.
It was no way.
Nah, he didn't say shit.
Alright, guys.
Give me a sec.
We're swapping accounts.
I know what the games are like at these hours.
We all know what that means.
Give me a sec.
It's account swap.
I'm gonna disappear, too, because since I have to swap Steam accounts.
No one commed anything.
I was like, what do you mean?
Whoa!
Alright, let me swap real quick, guys.
Oh, I need to close all my other stuff now, too.
Yeah, I was like, I'm pretty sure if I heard it, I would have not.
Also, the fact that he watched me die.
He was comming with his... No one said anything.
I just remember someone yelling at our hulk because that's all I heard.
Everyone was... That's the only thing that I heard from the comm before that was being like, what the fuck is our hulk doing?
What the fuck is our strange doing?
Why are we split up?
That was the only comm I heard throughout that entire game.
I have no idea what else they were listening to.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'll do that.
And then...
Yeah, I just... It was literally GG from character select.
People just hated each other.
The moment we went in, there was like nothing to save my team at that point.
It was just hopeless.
If you're GG from character select, then like, I don't know what to tell you.
Yeah, it was already game over by lobby.
Let's see.
Okay.
Ult account time.
I'm back.
Alright, I'm the ult now.
Yeah, I just tried one game just to see how it goes and I was like, alright, that's one game enough.
That's enough.
We either lose eternity or maybe we'll get lucky.
I don't know.
But welcome to my other account, DonKingKong.
My...
We have...
Yeah, my ult account.
That's DonKingKong, the legend.
But yeah, we'll see how it goes.
Maybe it'll be better.
I don't know.
That's crazy.
I hit all... like I hit...
I think I hit like every freeze but one freeze on the venom.
And then I got blamed.
And then he called He called me a slur and then...
That's all it takes.
One mistake and then you get called a slur.
That's crazy.
That sounds like my competitive games right there.
Oh, this is an old crosshair.
Oh, I don't like it.
Fuck.
Okay, I don't like this crosshair.
Oh my gosh.
I don't remember what my other crosshair is though.
Oh, I don't like this crosshair.
It's too tiny.
Fuck.
Okay.
I'll hide.
Yes, I don't hide.
Wait, this is where health packs are.
Okay.
I hide.
Okay, let me...
Let me look at my...
Does he know?
Okay.
This is an old crosshair of mine.
I need to change it.
I don't like that.
This one.
It's too hard to see.
I don't know what...
I'm too lazy to swap too.
See details.
Fuck.
Okay.
Gamers don't look up.
They never do.
Okay.
I haven't played in these lower lobbies in a long time.
We'll see how it goes.
Oh my god, since I'm in lower lobbies I feel a little excited.
Exciting today.
Maybe I'll play Adam.
I feel a little quirky.
I have nothing to lose.
I'm more afraid of lower lobbies because they're angrier people.
Lower lobbies?
They are a lot angrier as people compared to higher elo.
So that's why I'm a little afraid.
Especially if they're like...
Oh shit.
Okay.
Especially if they're like on the verge of eternity because a lot of them flip-flop between eternity and celestial so they're very, very angry people because they can't get above low eternity.
They're always trapped between celestial 1 and eternity.
So they care more.
Nice!
Yay!
I got my bands!
I can't run Adam.
We don't do triple support.
So maybe they'll wanna go triple support.
Let me fix my crosshair.
I don't remember.
That's the thing.
I don't know how to do my crosshair.
So we're just gonna wing it.
I just think it's too small.
Crosshair opacity...
Oh no, I don't want that to disappear.
Outline detail...
Maybe...
Stronger outline...
That...
And then...
No, I need the dot here.
Uh... Oh wait.
That...
And then... I don't like the reticle thingy.
The circle thingy there.
Yeah.
That...
Center gap...
Whoa!
No, that's fine.
Maybe like this.
I'll try this and see how I feel.
Alright, nice.
Triple support, let's go!
I don't know.
It's a little big.
Fuck, okay, this is a...
I don't know.
I might just use a dot.
I don't like this.
Okay, it's a little too big, yeah.
We'll see how this goes.
I do not like this crosshair.
At all.
I don't know.
I'll just go by...
I'll just go by, like, feel.
Alright, let's go!
Let's advance!
I did it after him.
So, like, we'll have this longer.
That's right.
Whoa, I'm so smart!
I did it after!
Wait, why did we let that tap, guys?
Why?
It's fine.
I rez.
I don't know why we did it after, but that's okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
We got it already?
Nice.
I definitely want to change my crosshair.
I'm not happy with it.
I can't aim right now with this one.
Oh, I cannot aim with this crosshair.
Oh, I need to die!
I'm gonna do a dot then.
This one's way too hard to aim with.
That was really fast.
I mean, I'm 73 right now.
I love abusing triple support.
It's so fun as a support player.
Hahaha!
Oh!
So bound!
All does nothing!
Hahaha!
Yay!
Let's go!
Alright.
I'll do...
I'll use a dot, I think.
I don't like it.
It's very hard to aim with.
Wait.
Have they had it?
Yeah, they did.
Okay, I'll rez.
I'll rez.
Unless...
It'll be fine, right?
It'll be fine.
Wait, they will be fine.
Yeah, not to worry.
Oh!
JK!
Rez time!
Hey there!
Hello!
Hahaha!
Unlucky!
Hey, I don't...
Oh, fuck!
Aw, they saw me.
That was funny, though.
I was like, hey.
That's awkward.
Very awkward, but...
Hahaha!
Okay.
That's pretty funny.
Oh, fuck.
I can't.
I can't do it in the middle of this.
Haha, surprise!
How did I lose that after I got the kill on the Adam?
Dude, what the fuck?
How the fuck did I lose that after?
I literally got like the...
the kill.
That's crazy.
Oh, I thought I would be dead.
Goodbye.
Hahaha!
He knew he fucked up there.
Oh, I thought he was gonna ult.
I was getting ready for that.
Goodbye.
Oh no, I was trying to...
Oh, I didn't shift in time.
That was my bad.
I threw that.
I should have shifted.
I was being really cocky there.
Oh, I played too cocky there.
I thought I didn't need it, so I was like, no shift!
But...
Yes shift, apparently.
Yes shift.
Wait, they used portal.
Nice.
They wasted portal.
I kept my shift, at least.
I'm playing with a little debuff though.
With no...
I'm playing with a little debuff.
With the lack of...
With the...
I don't like this crosshair.
It makes me sad.
I can't aim with it.
Wait, do I have raw input on this account?
I don't remember.
I think I did.
Yeah, I do.
I should have raw input on this.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go in here.
Well...
Soap on us, and I have rez.
I rez in the sky.
And then if she lives, then...
Oh!
Oh, he's dead.
Nice.
Why?
Oh, he had heals.
Okay, I was gonna say.
I'm gonna watch for a little bit.
Oh, what the fuck?!
He turned around?!
Really?!
He turned around!
I can't believe it!
It's not default.
Raw input is not default.
He actually...
I didn't even move!
I can't believe it!
I didn't even shoot!
He turned for no reason!
Okay.
Let me change it now.
Get rid of... I need to get rid of one.
Get rid of this.
See?
That's a good default.
Is that good?
I need the circle to be bigger.
Uh...
Dot with details.
Oh my god, there's too many!
Uh...
Dot with details.
I want this.
No, that's the outline.
Oh wait, that's the outline.
Outline with details.
Oh my gosh, my head is gonna explode.
There we go.
I need it to be a little bigger.
I can't see it.
There we go.
I'm way too blind of this.
Actually, no, this is too big.
Oh, this is fine.
There we go.
Alright.
I can't believe he saw me.
He ignored me for so long!
I literally was just standing there for so fucking long!
I was like, he can't see me.
And then he turns around?
Fucking freaks.
I should not have done that.
I wasted that.
What if I just left click?
We're fine.
I believe it.
They didn't even know how to use this.
Bye.
You're okay.
You're so healthy.
I so bought you so you can be healthier.
Look at that.
Nice.
Oh!
You hid from me!
There we go.
I give that to him just because I thought he was gonna die.
Oh, nope, but he's gonna die.
Okay.
Please don't die, guys.
What?
What the fuck?
Hey, guys.
I don't know about that.
I don't feel healthy.
What?
What is this ult that I'm hearing?
I hear some freaky ass ult right now.
Okay.
I'm backing up a little bit.
Oh my god.
Like, I'm just...
I just wanna know where did our Mantis go?
Is our Mantis okay?
No, please, Strange.
Not again, Strange.
Not again!
There we go.
This is not a good place for rezzes at all.
I heard the ult at their spot.
I was like, what happened?
Why was the ult at their spot?
Hey, there's a Mantis there.
We got this.
I believe in our Mantis.
Nice.
Okay, Mr. Mosquito, get out of here!
Is there a fucking mosquito?
Who's dying?
Oh, it's our Mantis.
Okay, there we go.
Like, she just walked up to me and just started fucking hitting me.
Like, freak.
Oh, and then I get exiled.
Okay, fuck you.
Actually, fuck you.
Okay.
Same.
Same, Miss Invisible.
I'll just fight down here.
You know what?
Fuck it, I believe.
Wait, where did she?
Why did she die there?
I was like, where did our Mantis die?
I was like, I saw our Mantis dead.
She was like, at their spot.
I was like, okay, I got our Mantis.
Don't worry.
I wasted that.
I legitimately was so fucking confident about our fucking Mantis being alive near us.
She was at their spot!
She was at their fucking spot!
I wasted that all, but that's okay.
We all meant nothing anyway.
The Mantis knows something we don't.
What is she doing?
What is in her mind?
She swapped sides!
Blue swapped to red side.
Puero, puero, puero!
Oh, never mind.
Oh, they're opening a puero.
Alright, that'll be on their high ground then.
No?
You open portal and you don't go on high ground?
That is some next-level strat, that's for sure.
Oh, they're running triple tank.
They're actual nerds.
They're running triple tank with triple support.
They have no damage though.
They have no damage.
I am the damage now.
I guess it's literally me and the... oh my god.
I guess I'd respawn in front of them.
Oh, I should not have respawned.
I mean, it's gonna work.
They're literally running triple tank.
We need like...
Yeah, I'm backing out.
Me and the star lord are the only damage.
That's okay, we'll save each other.
There we go.
I had to waste soul bond, but at least we're all six now.
And I got rez off of that?
Jesus Christ!
I actually built rez in like one fight.
That's crazy.
I don't remember what count There's like a specific thing to play to counter it.
Like, not Wolverine.
If Wolverine is bad, you can...
Oh god.
If Wolverine...
Is he at 100?
Yeah, he was.
That's smart.
Oh my god, that was really smart.
He was at 100.
He went through the invis.
There's like a character I was told in Rivals that if they run triple tank, it's not Wolverine, it's something else.
Like, Wolverine helps too, but like, there's a character stronger than Wolverine against triple tank, and I don't remember what it was on the top of my head.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Soul bonus.
Alright.
Let's go!
Oh nice, he didn't have ult.
Nice.
Control C's!
Alright.
Was it Moon Knight?
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Is it worth?
I think it's worth it.
They're fighting now.
I want us to be six before we fight.
I think it's worth it because they would have pushed us if it wasn't.
Now we have like, we got extra...
I wish I have another.
I wish I have another one.
I'm sorry, buddy.
I didn't think you would insta-die.
Not gonna lie.
That's the only reason why.
I didn't think you would insta-die.
Okay, it's not worth it anymore.
There's no...
Okay.
We want four.
There we go.
Alright.
Okay.
Can't be that bad now.
Alright.
That was awkward though.
Oh god.
Okay.
I'll take that.
I think that...
Not gonna lie...
I carry that.
I 100% carry that fight.
There's no way I did not carry that after what I just did for the team.
Not even close.
It's like, goodbye Hulk!
Goodbye!
I take that.
I feel that.
Fly high!
I think he made it.
Thank you for the Twitch prompt.
Thank you.
That was easy.
Easiest lowkey game of my life.
He met God.
I fucked him over like two times too.
Like, I don't know why he tried to solo on me.
He solo ulted me and lost his entire fucking life.
Yeah, this is my ulti count.
Yeah.
It's my ulti count.
It's my level 20 Eternity ulti count.
It's not that hard to get to Eternity.
Sorry.
Like, Grandmaster in Celestial is so inflated.
It's so inflated that it's really easy to climb if you've been in Eternity before.
That's what I'll say.
Like, if you've been in Eternity before, there's so many inflated players in GM and Celestial because there was no rank reset.
As long as like, um, you know what you're doing, it's a lot easier to climb if you've been in Eternity before.
You're a little... wild.
So I'll play Adam.
Yeah, like like, I feel like you can get to GM if you just spam play.
Oh yeah, we should spam bug you.
Like, you can get to GM by just playing so much.
You can just play enough and then you'll get to GM.
I've been hella ticked.
Really?
There's three hella players running around in the sky.
It's 2-3 AM.
It's one fucking...
Are they really just bad hella?
I guess.
I guess in a higher elo, everybody's a good hella player.
Because we have a low-key player and they'll just do resets.
And I'll just play Mantis with this.
There's no reason.
If we're doing...
Oh, okay.
I guess I'll go Luna?
I was gonna say, I'd play Mantis if we're in triple support then.
Like, the thing is in higher elo, almost every player every DPS player is a decent enough hella player so there's no reason to ban hella.
Most likely just ban Groot.
We ban things where you can...
Groot is just so oppressive to play against.
You don't get why...
Bucky is the most...
The best DPS character.
In competitive and like actual esport competitive and in high elo.
Bucky is the best character.
Best DPS now.
That's why he gets banned all the time.
It's Bucky and Groot.
That's like the most oppressive characters.
And now it's... and Venom now too.
Venom is so fucking...
I hate playing against Venom players in one of our lobbies.
It's so fucking frustrating.
It's actually incredibly frustrating to play against because they're all really good too.
And then even with freezes it's like my entire team has to do something about it.
Oh there is a Flanking Jeff.
So you know what that means.
Just ignore him.
Don't align.
That's unfortunate.
That's what we get when we have to play with Jeff.
You guys wanted to play with against Groot.
You guys wanted to.
You wanted this.
You wanted to play against Groot.
I would have banned Groot the first thing.
Groot is my first ban.
Groot is so fucking annoying.
I hate Groot.
They wanted to keep Groot.
This is what happened.
They wanted this.
They fucking wanted this.
I want this.
Oh my god.
Why are we here?
I just realized where we were.
Oh no, I'm so close.
No, I'm at 96.
I didn't realize we're the strange fucking portalist.
Why are we there?
Oh we got this.
I was like, wait.
What?
I just realized where we were.
Thank god this is an ulti camp.
It is good.
But I'm not going to be that rocket player.
Okay.
I forgot that...
Alright, where's the...
Why?
Wait, what?
What?
Why did...
I had so much time with my ult.
I'm going lowkey.
After that.
Nerd boy is not it.
What is he gonna...
I...
Um...
That...
She's like...
She's like, woah, you supported too?
Bro, check this out.
That's fine.
Oh, that's not fine.
I couldn't do anything.
The group was just on my ass.
Like, I'm so confused.
Like...
Why?
Why did he ult that?
There was no reason to.
I mean, they ban.
They ban.
Fucking really.
That's why I hate playing against group players.
I fucking hate playing against group players.
Goddammit.
Never anymore.
I'm never...
I'm never fucking letting group get unbanned.
It doesn't matter what ELO I am.
It's the most...
Stupid ELO.
It's the most stupid character I have to play with and play against.
I might have to do this just to keep my venom alive.
It's fine.
I believe.
The Psylocke technically is supposed to counter Jeff.
We'll see soon.
If that's the case.
If you play Psylocke, you're a Jeff counter.
So like, we'll see.
We'll see.
I don't know why my invisible woman does not want to support me.
She just hates me, I guess.
She just fucking hates me.
She doesn't look behind her.
I don't understand.
Yeah, Psylocke counters Jeff.
It does.
It's a Jeff counter.
Cool.
Cool?
That's cool.
Like...
Psylocke counters Jeff because at Psylocke, you can easily kill Jeff.
Very fast.
I know this because every time we're against a Jeff player in high ELO in high Eternity, you always go...
One of your DPS swaps to Psylocke and then that Jeff cannot do anything after that.
That Jeff will actually basically be useless.
Especially when he ults.
A Psylocke can just ult the Jeff ult.
Scarlet Witch is useless.
No one plays Psy.
I only know one person that plays Scarlet Witch in high ELO and he swaps if he gets countered.
And he also gets avoided.
I avoid him non-stop.
He's decent at like Bucky but like...
I'd rather have a DPS player that actually plays Bucky every time.
I really want to try that, Loki.
I think that would work, but we can try Dot.
Let's try Dot.
Yeah, Scarlet Witch at high ELO is fucking troll.
I play Scarlet Witch when he can just run Psylocke.
No one's listening to that guy.
I don't even know who was talking, not gonna lie.
I do not know who was talking.
I'm not playing Luna with this.
I might as well just get better at Loki.
Loki is one of the characters that I have yet to master.
Which is surprising because um, you know.
Loki doki.
Is he...
Yeah.
Goodbye.
Literally that's all he needs to do.
He just needs to heal me.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll just sit on cart.
I'm just cart bitch.
Cart bitch!
Yay!
Literally all he needs to do is literally just look at me.
That's all he needs to do.
That's sad.
Are you really?
Please.
Hahaha!
There you go.
I can literally just stand there.
They have to figure out which one is the real me.
Okay, cool.
Oh, we did not need that!
But that's alright.
I'm trying!
Fuck, okay.
Hey, do you like have my invuln?
Woo!
Go invuln!
Where am I?
Hahaha!
Woah!
That's fine, I'll just walk over.
At least they have my invuln guys!
Yippee!
I'll just stand there like this.
Nevermind, I guess I don't just stand there like that.
Where's my cloak?
That was an accident.
How did I?
Oh my god.
Woo!
How did I get that?
Oh, I fucked up my settings.
It shouldn't be instant.
I realized I don't have this.
Hahaha!
I didn't have this!
I was like, where did my cloak?
I was in front of my cloak!
What happened?
Hahaha!
Was I not in front of my cloak?
I don't know what the fuck happened to my cloak.
It was my ulti count so I didn't have my double confirm.
Did she like cloak herself?
Is that what happened?
Please, look at me!
Turn around!
Oh my god!
I just need you to be aware of your surroundings!
Holy shit!
Just be...
Just be aware of your surroundings.
That's all I ask.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Support not...
I love it when supports don't support each other.
They're my favorite pastime in the world.
It's actually my favorite pastime.
It didn't matter what I do.
Hahaha!
Maybe?
Oh my god.
I can't do anything.
He got me out of my cloak instantly.
He got me out of invisibility instantly.
How would Mantis help?
How would it help you?
Please explain how Mantis would be any better against Jeff!
If anything, you should go sue!
If anything, go sue!
So you can push him away!
How would...
How would Mantis be any better?
I don't understand your logic.
I just don't understand the logic for this.
Oh my god.
Guys, I need...
Please.
I need another...
Where is a different support that I can...
That's not...
Please.
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
I...
If you don't want to die to Jeff, please sue!
This is gonna mean a lot right here.
I have double support up for sure.
Okay.
Like, makes zero sense.
Goodbye.
It doesn't matter where I go.
It doesn't matter what happens.
I can't...
What do you want me to do?
He ulted me in front of them!
I got ulted into Jeff and he threw me into team.
I...
What do you mean?
I didn't mean to copy ult early!
How...
How could you not ult them?
You should have copied...
What do you mean?
He go yum yum yum and I was yum yum dead.
You should have copied early.
Just don't get eaten, I guess.
Predict the E that happens in one second.
Just predicted, Forehead!
Oh, let me... Yeah, let me do that now!
There you go, let's go!
Isn't that what you wanted?
Oh, they're fucking dead.
They said that.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Fuck, I did not expect to be a fucking lowkey right now.
Like, yeah?
Okay, thank you.
It's alright.
I ulted early, that's what they wanted.
Fucking om yum yum.
Om yum yum, just ult early.
Sorry, that made me so spiteful.
Like, what the fuck?
Can't just...
Let go!
Let's go!
Om yum yum!
Let's fucking go, I guess.
There we go.
I wish they would do that for me sometimes.
Just trying to get these up.
Okay, I need to reload.
Sorry guys, I'm fucking reloading right now.
Let's forget and dance.
Forget and dance.
Yippee!
Jeff just does his own thing.
You know what counters Jeff?
You ignore the Jeff and walk forward.
Or the supports support each other.
But like, I can't have that.
Apparently.
That doesn't exist.
Alright.
Alright, I could go Sue here and then maybe I'll push the Jeff away.
Maybe that's...
You think that will work, guys?
If I went...
I guess I'll push the Jeff away.
I like the Loki more.
Alright.
I feel like I survived more on Loki.
I went Loki because of the lack of survivability of my other support player.
But I could go invisible.
That's the thing.
I'm just thinking like I could push him and go invisible too.
But then like, Loki does give me more heals.
We'll see.
Yeah, I don't understand.
I'll never understand.
Okay.
I thought he'd push up!
I'm gonna save my shield.
I have to push the Jeff this way.
No, I can't.
Yeah, I'm gonna go Loki.
I'm gonna go Loki and use Enron.
I have to push one or the other and I chose...
I chose the group because he was in front of me.
I was just like, who do I push off?
The guy that's on top of me right now or the Jeff that's beside me?
I don't really wanna use my clones but
yeah, fuck this.
I have to use Envon!
Oh!
Alright,
here we go.
I'm going invisible.
Now you can't hit me.
That's the entire pattern.
Alright.
What do you mean no support out?
LIE!
I mean, we got the support out at least.
I don't wanna use...
Yeah, that's what I said.
Where's our...
Alright.
Okay.
I dance now.
Let's dance.
Let's go.
Oh, goodbye Luna.
How did he...
Oh, he got ulted.
I was gonna say how did he get over there?
That's how.
Okay.
I hear him.
No more bump bump.
Apparently, no more.
Okay.
That's good.
I got my Envon out at least.
The only issue is that they do have Groot ult though now.
Me!
Yippee!
As foretold.
As foretold, the Groot ult shows up.
The moment.
I knew it was gonna show up.
That moment.
I am a prophet.
You know what that's called?
Ult tracking.
Woah!
Oh my gosh.
The power of ult tracking.
That's the worst part about knowing when ults show up.
Is that you have nothing...
You can't do anything about it.
Oh man, if we just run triple support it gets countered.
There's nothing I can do.
Yeah, don't chase him.
If we play well enough together...
There's nothing I can do.
I don't chase.
I literally just walk...
Our fucking Luna chases him for some reason.
Our Luna chases.
They'll be coming in 30 seconds.
Stay strong.
It's like when you know what ult's coming up...
And you can't do anything about it.
I had no invuln.
Had to use invulns for the Namor ult.
Witch Magneto can peel the supports harder.
I know, a little bit.
I got shit to do.
I know, I know.
Brother, I...
Brother, I can't be...
I got shit to do, brother.
I can't be healing first.
Sorry, I'm not healing now.
Because that shit was fucking hilarious.
What the fuck is going on?
Alright.
He's got shit to do, guys.
He can't be...
Sorry.
I had to heal the tank.
Sorry, Luna.
That little switcheroo on the Jeff was so...
He was just like, what?
I like how they said to peel for our support and there was no peel.
I literally was like...
I was like...
Okay, I disappear now.
That was my peel.
I disappear for...
Okay.
I hope that helps a little.
Just a little though.
I can't do much about it.
This is crazy.
You got a lowkey greener there, man.
You just won the fight.
What?
What do you mean?
I literally...
The moment I got there, I died last.
What are they on about?
I died last.
I walked there as fast as I could.
My little legs could take me.
If we lamped there, we could have won.
What?
I did lamp though.
Oh, there's another lamp.
I disappear.
I die.
What do I do there?
I just die.
Here I go.
Remember when they said they'd peel for our support?
I don't think that happened.
I don't think our support ever got peeled.
Yeah, you could go invisible and then...
You go invisible and...
And then you don't get ulted.
We just never got peeled at all.
To be fair, I could have said something.
But I was just like...
But I wasn't the one that was in the most trouble.
It was our other support that was getting bullied even more.
It was only when our other support dies...
When he starts going after me.
But at that point, there was just no saving me.
Our other support never said anything too.
So it was like...
I guess we both die.
You had to voice vocalize the peel too.
But how to...
How to beat a Jeff...
Is to literally ignore him.
If you just are Luna...
Try to 1v1 the Jeff every time.
Which was like...
A choice.
I mean, he literally swapped to Mantis.
I was like, why are you on Mantis?
I could have said something.
But I also don't feel like talking right now.
In game.
Especially...
Right now at 3.30 in the morning.
Oh, my Celestial lobbies.
Wow.
It's 3.30 right now.
I don't expect people to be communicating at all.
What do I feel like?
Oh, we have a Mantis.
I have to go main heal.
That means...
I'm on another account.
Do we have a name?
Oh, nice.
I'm gonna...
We're solo thing.
Which is the worst thing you can go.
Why Cloak and Dagger?
Are you stupid?
I'm getting water.
Did my team do the right bans?
Oh, thank god.
We ban Adam?
When I'm clearly hovering over Adam?
They are stupid.
Oh, my god.
My little...
Special little guys.
Oh, look at that, bro.
What a fucking goat.
My special little guys.
Wait, was it him that banned it?
3 support is...
The easiest thing you can play in rank.
It doesn't work in competitive esports.
Triple support and triple tank is the easiest Ongobunga comp you can win if you're very desperate for ELO.
Or if you have 3 supports.
And in this ELO, there's a lot of support players.
But the thing is, as a solo tank, it's not it.
It's the one that's most...
The thing is, one of the top 3 to tanks you should not run as a solo tank.
Oh, okay.
Fuck me, I guess.
Guess I'll play on fucking low ground.
Doesn't let me play on.
I mean...
I need to learn.
The thing I don't know how to do low key very well is my F.
I'm really bad at using my F.
Uh...
I'm really bad at using my F for...
Oh my god.
This is why we don't solo tank.
That's the thing.
I don't know how to use my F well enough.
I like always mess it up.
I mess it up a lot.
Mag won.
I have to reload.
You can run him.
You just can't run him as a solo tank.
Oh, I hear you.
How did he not...
Taz!
LOL This is what separates a Celestial player from an Eternity player.
LOL Like...
How are you not aware?
You press tab.
Please tell me they...
Okay.
Hey guys.
You know what would be cool right now?
Luna, flash damage when I ult.
No, no, no, no, no.
I missed.
LOL LOL LOL LOL LOL There we go.
LOL That's very unfortunate that he missed though.
LOL
There we go.
That's unfortunate.
I missed.
Nice try though.
Nice try.
Appreciate... Good effort.
Good effort.
Very good effort.
At least he was honest.
I'm surprised I didn't get ulted there.
I stood next to my Mag because it's like...
You assume that your Mag has all...
Or not all, has like...
Yeah, I got you.
Oh, there he is.
We're just flanking you guys.
Oh, there we go.
And we still have Manta's ult.
We're gonna use it, right?
Oh, wait.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, he didn't kill him in time.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine, I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
I'm coming back, guys.
There is a Bucky, so I might have to swap off Loki.
I don't know.
Depends on like how well...
How...
How much they take advantage.
That's unlucky.
We got nothing.
Yeah, that's why I was like...
I was like... It's unfortunate.
I might have to swap off Loki if he's a good enough Bucky.
It's fine, I believe.
I believe.
I didn't believe anymore.
I...
Hello, I'm back.
I did not want to be back.
I did not consent to be back, but I'm back.
I'm back.
Alright.
Damn, I'm healing botting too much.
I need DPS as Loki.
I'm too scared to go up.
I'm heal botting way too much.
I need to do more damage.
I have like three of me.
There's three of me.
I should be doing damage.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Okay.
What is hitting me?
There it is.
Okay.
Oh fuck, I didn't realize I was still Luna.
Oh, thank god.
I got the shift ready for him though.
Oh, that's unlucky for him.
I have to do this for our Mag because I don't think he'll live.
Guys.
There's these.
Why did we just let him do that?
Why did we just let him have squids like that?
Guys.
Okay, he's not getting it from me.
That's for sure.
Who is?
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
You know what?
You know what I feel like playing?
No way.
Do I do it?
Let's go.
It's time.
This is 4am Doki.
4am Doki's about to...
I've lost my mind.
Bruh.
This is gonna be the most engaging gameplay of your time.
Guys.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why don't you play Luna?
That's fine.
Don't worry, we have res.
Heals for days.
This is gonna be the most engaging gameplay you've ever seen.
Not boring.
No, not boring at all.
Oh my god, this is it.
Guys, okay, I was gonna say like guys.
Don't worry, if I never stop holding right click, they'll never die.
That's how it goes, right?
That should be how it goes.
Whoa, I heal myself too.
That's the best part.
Go in there.
You got- oh.
Oh my god, don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
Just- oh, that's unfortunate.
That's very unfortunate for you.
Strange.
Guys, will we ever kill the Magneto?
Let's find out.
Where is my team?
You gotta look for Luna.
What do you want me to do?
It's not my fault we're losing.
It's absolutely not my fault.
It's not.
It's not Roggen's fault.
I guess I can say that for a lot of reasons.
It is definitely- Yeah, not my fault.
I literally was the only one healing there.
Let me know when you're ready.
She knows, they know, they know.
That's crazy that I was playing.
No, our Luna complained that it was my fault.
Really?
That was actually- That was not the blame here.
Post supports.
That's crazy.
So maybe-
Welp.
Hey, I lived.
Let's just- Let's freaking go up.
Welp.
Welp, I lived.
That's how you fucking play in eternity.
I don't think they'll understand that.
I don't think they have the game sense for that.
Easy.
Welp.
It's surprising how they don't even kill squids, too.
It's winnable, chat.
It's winnable, yes.
Don't have a weak mental.
Locked in.
That's crazy.
I don't usually have a weak mental, to be honest with you.
We're just getting walked.
Or being dumb, is the word.
Oh no, our team is incredibly stupid.
But it is this- It's three in the morning.
I am not playing as if like- Literally, this stream just walks up to us.
Don't walk.
If you're playing at four in the morning, you do not come into these lobbies thinking that these games are gonna be like- Bro, I have the least deaths out of all my support.
How am I getting blamed?
I literally played the best positioning out of my supports.
And I'm not playing the best positioning right now.
I'm playing so fucking stupid.
What?
That's what I'm fucking saying, bro.
That's what I've been saying this whole goddamn game.
We got Goro.
At least I get validated.
I'm getting validation.
I think I'll die.
Okay.
You do not go in at 4am expecting these games to go the way they're gonna go.
I have Agumoto though.
You know what would be great?
If we had a Luna ult there.
Absolutely.
There we go.
Oh, they charged it.
Did they charge it?
Let's see.
What is this crosshair?
Yeah, it was charged.
Oh, that's unlucky.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's Luna.
I'm betting it's Luna.
Holy fuck.
We finally got a break in their defenses.
And y'all niggas don't want to move this shit up.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
These people are not happy.
Bro, I am trying my best to keep you up right now.
Oh my god.
Don't talk shit in chat, guys.
This is like one of those moments.
If you talk shit in chat, it'll fucking bite you in the ass.
It's like, I talk shit on stream because they're not watching.
Karma's always gonna get you if you talk shit in chat.
That's crazy.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
That's why you don't talk shit in chat.
That's why I don't talk too.
It's like, at this time, on my alt account, I'm like, fuck that.
Yeah, the moment you do it, you're inviting that in for people to just dogpile you.
There's no...
Yeah, you don't speak.
I don't know why you would ever invite that in.
Yeah, the risk is like, especially as a...
DPS player, I can see DPS player talking shit a lot.
Because it's just the way it is.
But like, when you're a support player, you will get dogpiled so fucking hard as a support player.
So you try to never start shit unless you know you're on the right side of history.
You don't start shit unless you know you're on the right side of history.
Because if you're on the right side, people, your team will support you.
But like, I knew the problem was not me that time on Rocket.
I was absolutely not the problem there on Rocket.
I was...
Wait, I'm pretty sure this person avoided me.
I don't have to avoid them.
I don't have to waste my avoid.
Okay.
Yeah.
You don't get flayed.
That's why I didn't say nothing.
I don't have to...
You're right.
I should not risk it.
I don't want to risk it.
You're right, guys.
That's crazy.
I liked how...
I have like three slots anyway.
I liked how there's that support playing me and then my entire team was like, that Rocket was not the problem.
They were like, it was you.
I was like, yay!
Validation.
It's not me.
I got validated the one time I wanted to play Rocket.
Clearly, nobody did anything.
I literally just ran up and just started healing.
I would say I was heal botting as Loki 100%.
I was not...
Um...
I was not doing damage as Loki enough, but I was also like playing position a lot.
Like, I was trying to play where because I was scared I was gonna get picked because there were so many flankers around us that I didn't want to play in a way that I was gonna get killed.
So I was trying to make sure I'm safe as well because there was that fucking Namor and Bucky.
Namor and Bucky were running around.
But like definitely was not... I did not get any kills as Loki.
I could have.
I didn't...
I felt like I didn't do enough damage there for Loki.
But...
I'm still learning Loki.
Loki's like the character I haven't yet to figure out.
I don't know how to play Loki that well yet.
Uh... The legend...
Why are we losing Luna ult?
Yeah, that's why I'm playing Loki.
Because Loki is so strong.
He's the strongest healer at the moment.
Loki is currently, um...
the strongest support current meta.
And he's the only support I don't know how to play right now.
Um... Because there's like so many like...
There's so many like things you can do on Loki too.
Like the...
You know, changing positions.
I think like changing positions really hard too.
And place... I think placing the clones is like incredibly difficult to do in terms of positioning wise.
I'm like, where do I put my clones?
I don't fucking know.
Where are people?
Where are people at?
That was crazy.
Oh, what the fuck?
Goodbye.
Bye.
Hello little boy.
That's not fair.
Wait, what the fuck?
I got hit already.
You hit me first!
What the...
Oh wait, it's just... Is this an RP lobby again?
There's a no.
Okay.
He still doesn't know.
Is this an RP lobby?
Why?
Why you kept going?
Okay.
Yeah, he started it.
He hit me first.
All lobbies are RP lobbies.
That rocket looks like a roleplay.
Goodbye.
Maybe like, open your eyes?
It is 4 in the morning.
5 slash 7 in the morning for Easties.
Oh no, I'm on a PST server.
West Coast server.
I'm a little... I'm on my... So we're all 4am right now.
Right here.
Who is Don King Kong?
Don King Kong is a...
Oh wait.
That's sad.
Why you running?
Huh?
Oh, that's cute.
That's cute, buddy.
That's so cute.
Oh, I got bad RNG.
I got bad RNG.
I did not want to solo out him.
Disappear.
Get baited.
Baited.
That's sad.
I mean, at least he was...
He was confident.
That guy is definitely not a bot.
He really wanted me dead.
He really wanted me to fucking die.
Holy shit.
Wait, do we have an Iron Fist?
We have an Iron Fist.
I want the C.
I never get a chance to play with the C move a lot.
Rare Luna moment.
I say as I practically play Luna as much as I can.
On my main.
Playing Luna on my main.
Rare Luna moment.
Oh, thank god.
They actually want to...
Is your C good?
It's okay.
I just don't get to use it a lot.
I keep forgetting to use it, so I'm trying to take as much opportunity to actually use the C move.
So I can have it ingrained in my head.
Because I always forget.
So what draws you to be a support mate?
My lack of DPS skill.
And the fact that I'm not a masochist to play a tank.
I'm gonna say the truth.
I can practice as hard as I could on DPS, but I know my ceiling when it comes to playing DPS.
I don't think I could be good enough to be a DPS player in eternity.
Siren and thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
But I'm a tank mate.
Congratulations, you hate yourself.
So this is the C move.
Boom!
I always forget to use it, so I try to take an opportunity to use it when I remember to.
Let's go!
Nice, okay.
Please, I'm only playing Luna because I want to use the C.
Sheet, man.
I've been killing every game.
Unless you want my drafting play, that's all I got.
Welcome to our rank!
You want to be a DPS player?
You gotta do it with a support mate.
Oh, shit.
Wait,
what?
What do you mean by two?
Wait, we're running Cloak?
Okay.
That's five.
Oh, I love it when I know there's another flanker here.
That's gonna be behind me any second now.
We heal each other.
We keep each other alive.
What?
Oh my god, I got the fucking random Psylocke.
He like stood in front of my shot.
I was like, where did this guy come from?
Psylocke literally stood in front of my shot.
It's like, peek-a-boo.
It's fine.
Guys, don't worry.
I have C.
If I get flanked, I have the game move.
Please, look behind me.
Oh my god, he got booped up.
Nice.
Nice cool bubble.
My team.
Nice.
Woah!
I don't have another C.
Oh, why did he cloak up?
He could've tanked it!
Never cloak a Psylocke ult because it is um, it fucks over the other players.
You can still die, because there were three of us, we could've all tanked it together.
We could've tanked the...
Don't worry, I got the C move.
I remember to use it this time.
Oh, he fucked it up.
Don't worry, I healed us!
I wasted it though.
Okay, I should not have used it.
I should not have used it.
Oh, I'm still not alive.
I should not have used it there.
I wanted to save our Bucky, but I forgot to always use it for myself.
Who cares about what my fucking Bucky needed.
Alright.
Only care about my life.
Alright, guys.
Alright, thing is not surviving at all.
Absolutely.
Okay.
I don't know where that fucking bomb's gonna go, so...
WOAH!
Oh, wow!
What?
Oh my god, the ult!
I'm so unlucky!
The ult came down the moment- Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
He's gonna get that, right?
He's gonna keep getting that, right?
No, my C!
Don't worry, I'm coming back, guys.
Don't worry.
Is this winnable?
You and I!
You and me!
Let's go!
Oh my god.
You and me!
Okay, nevermind.
Goodbye, Wolverine.
Goodbye.
I just don't think we should run...
I don't know.
Goodbye.
I think we should run Sue for this, just cause like...
Just cause of the fact that- You guys gotta just walk to us, man, when you're getting dove instead of being back.
I was.
I was playing up front with you guys.
I was up front, wasn't I?
I don't remember.
I don't think I died.
I never died by flankers.
No!
What's the point?
What if I just play Sue?
I play Sue for him.
I can push him back.
Yeah, I died to the Psylocke once and it was the ult.
I was like, what?
I was not getting fucked over by flankers.
At all.
I was having a grand old time, not gonna lie.
Oh, I don't think he plays Sue, that's why.
Also, thank you for the raid!
I really appreciate it.
Hello, everybody!
For those who don't know me.
Also, thank you for the raid, Yuku and Ara.
Those who don't know me, my name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but I'm on Twitch right now to get my Marble Rivals hours up.
For my Marble Rivals partnership.
Yeah, you should check me out on YouTube.
You like my content.
And then also, buy my merch.
I think the best way to support a streamer is merch and...
I think like, merches.
Merch and views.
Aww.
What?
Is he okay?
Okay.
They let him walk up to me!
Holy shit!
I even pushed him away!
What?!
Pushed him away!
Y'all can go Loki or something.
Loki?
What?
Loki is banned!
I would if I could.
I wanna learn Loki.
Doesn't know.
I'm gonna save my push on the flankers at this point.
Okay.
Alright!
Let's see if I live!
Aww!
He doesn't know.
Okay, now he knows.
Now he knows.
We can't play Loki.
Why?
Why did we ban Namor?
Because Namor is a fucking terrible play against.
Because we have Iron Fist.
What the fuck?
We had flank...
We had flanker players.
The fuck does he mean?
There we go.
Okay, I should ult first.
Alright.
I used pull.
Nevermind.
Never use pull and push for my team.
I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
They don't know where I am.
They won't know where I am.
Don't worry.
There is...
Goodbye.
Nevermind.
Worry.
I literally showed up and it was over.
It was fucking over.
I mean...
Guys, I don't think I like the C move anymore.
I...
Nice try everybody.
Nice try.
I think I went to Celestial for that.
It's alright.
It's an ult account.
That's why I was like...
What account do I play at 4 in the morning?
Ouch.
I can get it back.
It's fine.
This account has fucking went through worse.
How many ult accounts do I have?
I only have one... Well, I had one Eternity ult account.
Now I have one main account.
And that's 200 points at the moment.
And then...
I don't even play that often anymore though because I'm so busy with other stuff.
I just play for stream now.
And I have this account.
I have two Celestial accounts now.
And... No, this is my ult account.
That's why it's not Doki Bird.
It's not Doki Bird.
It's alright.
Games at this time is not about winning at the morning.
Games at this time is about meeting the most interesting people who are playing at this time as their hobby.
Games at this time is whoever's...
For me, I'm playing at this time because this is the only time I can play for my quota hours because it's literally my job.
So people who play at this time that's just for out of their own free will is very interesting.
XD See?
Yeah, the demons come out at 4 in the morning.
100%.
I'm watching the demons right now.
Creatures of the night.
They are still gaming at this time.
Well, I'm on this account.
It's only 25.
The hell spawns.
What's the worst rank session I've had?
When I played for 13 hours and I just went up one game.
That was very rough.
That was incredibly rough.
I know I have to censor this for sure.
For that one crash on our Luna.
I definitely have to censor it.
That guy was not having a good day.
Oh, this guy is already not having a good day.
Time to warm up.
This is an RP server.
Goddamn.
Wait, no.
They're just bad.
I was like, wait, are they roleplaying?
No, they're literally missing every fucking shot.
XD Holy shit.
The fucking Panther.
Oh my God.
That was...
That's crazy.
The fucking Panther was crazy to watch.
I legitimately just thought they were just roleplaying.
But they were just bad.
Okay, are you?
Okay, no.
You're real.
XD You're definitely...
Mine.
XD
That's interesting.
Haven't been in Celestia in a while.
That's a lie.
I had to rank up this account to eternity.
Not purposely, but I actually ranked up this account to eternity just for stream's sake.
And now it's back in Celestia.
Sad.
So sad.
Alas.
I ranked it up just for a stream.
Maybe I can...
Okay, maybe if I try.
Alright.
No, trying is for...
Trying... Oh.
Alright, trying is not an option anymore.
Trying is not an option anymore.
It hurts less, guys.
It hurts less if I take it less seriously, which is what I've noticed.
It's trying is...
It hurts...
It makes me feel a little less sad.
Wait, what?
Who banned or owned it?
What?
Someone...
Someone banned their own champ?
Oh, that's crazy.
Oh,
they got a shark main.
Okay.
No wonder.
Okay, I was gonna be like, oh my god.
That's why.
Okay.
I was gonna say.
That's insane.
They actually... Okay.
Where do I play Loki?
Alright, guys.
Let's do Loki.
I feel Loki today.
Might as well learn.
Like, there's no point.
I play Luna so much in my main.
I wanna learn Loki.
I actually wanna learn this character.
Oh, I forgot.
I wish I could gift like currency to my other accounts.
Because I have so much currency.
Free currency that I got from the sponsor and the tournament.
From tournaments and stuff.
So, but I can't gift it to... I wish I can.
I feel like if you can start gifting stuff on the moment they start doing gifts and stuff, they're gonna make so much money.
I don't know how people play Loki on this map.
We'll figure it out.
I don't know.
Maybe they don't know.
I put it too far.
I definitely put it too far up.
I don't think it's gonna do anything.
Yeah, it's definitely not gonna do much.
What the fuck already?
Hahahahaha Where's my team?
I was like where's the rest of my team?
Look, I am trying my best right now, okay?
I have three of me shooting at one guy.
I think my computer is about to crash.
Taaaaa Hahahaha Hahahaha Guys, don't you love hearing that?
Woo.
I love it.
Hahahaha
I love to hear that.
When they're like, guys, my computer Oh, I wanted to press F.
That was unlucky.
Don't worry, I can press shift whenever.
But don't die though.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, um.
Get over here.
Okay.
We... we advance with that.
There we go.
Oh wait, that's not cool.
That is not cool, but that's okay.
Don't worry, I believe in you, Hella!
That's right, Hella!
Don't worry!
I have this too!
It's gone, it's gone.
Nice bubble.
It was afterwards, but nice bubble.
Don't worry.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know what I'm...
Don't even let it win.
Oh!
Maybe I am a low-key player!
Look at that!
Oh my god!
Don't worry.
I don't know what I'm doing on low-key.
But do not be afraid.
Bro, what is going on?
What the fuck?
Your HP goes so low in like one second.
Don't worry, I got you.
Never worry.
What I've learned is that I can just do splash damage like this.
Where's my...
Woah!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I did not realize everybody was gonna be dead.
Oh...
I...
How the fuck?
Okay, look guys.
How was I supposed to know you were all just gonna die like that?
What the fuck?
Can anyone touch?
Oh, okay.
Wait, okay, wait, wait.
It's possible.
Oh, nice!
Oh no, not the born again.
That's fine.
There we go.
Nice!
Wait...
I just shoot on the ground at this point.
Guys, here's my pro tip.
If you can't aim as low-key...
Low-key, left-click heals is splash damage.
So I just shoot at the floor.
I just shoot the floor because eventually it heals.
That's what I love about low-key.
I don't actually have to aim.
I just shoot the floor.
That's true.
The Atom Rest was literally behind us.
Yeah.
Ignore that, bro.
Slash does more...
Slash does more healing, funny enough.
Yeah, that's the best part.
Why aim when I can just shoot the floor?
There's only one Torch player I've...
Oh wait, maybe I could technically play with a human Torch one trick.
Wait, let me see if he's online.
He wanted to play...
I know this guy since Overwatch 1.
And you guys might... OG Overwatch players might recognize him.
But his name is Iron.
And he used to be the Hanzo one trick in EU Overwatch.
And at one point, he did a series where he tried to prove to people...
That you can one trick as Mercy without using any voice comms.
And with just the soundboard.
And he did an unranked top...
I don't remember if it was an unranked top 500 Mercy.
With just the soundboard.
And he did it.
I think he did it incredibly fast too.
But he's basically a...
He's a Mercy one trick.
Oh, he's a...
Not Mercy one trick, sorry.
He is a...
He is a Hanzo one trick that proved that you can one trick as Mercy without...
Without any actual comms.
It's actually...
And now he's a Human Torch one trick.
He just likes to do crazy shit.
But yeah, you might recognize his name.
Because his name is Iron.
Oh, he's portaling.
Nice.
And he's EU, so he might be awake.
Hahaha.
What?
How did he get across?
Did he fuck up the portal?
Stay in my thingy if you wanna be...
Alive.
Oh, stay in my thingy.
Stay in my thingy if you wanna be alive.
Stay in my thingy.
Hahaha.
Did he think that's still me?
Bro, what?
Why would I stand still?
Oh, he was very happy about winning.
Why did I die?
I thought I was still there.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
This is the...
Keep clipping Celestial players, pal.
Who's the fucking player?
What?
Who is he trash talking?
Is there a streamer on the enemy team?
Oh my god, guys.
There might be a streamer on the enemy team.
Let me see if I'll ask if the...
If he wants to play.
I know he like, asked me if I wanna play.
Are you awake now?
I'm down to play now since I'm streaming.
Oh no!
He has a weird stream...
He has a weird sleeping schedule.
The time I play EU hours.
This guy has a weird...
He has an NA sleep schedule.
Oh my god.
I didn't read his previous message.
A couple of days anyway.
Alright.
No!
I could've played with a fucking...
Torch one trick.
In Eternity 200.
Oh, I might be too...
I know it's like within 200 points.
Yeah, this guy hit...
Hit Eternity 200 points with just a human torch.
Oh my god, right?
Imagine having a weird sleep schedule.
Couldn't be me.
Uh, Galaxy, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Bucky and Techno, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Really appreciate it.
Just like...
No.
I can change my sleep schedule anytime I want, guys.
Anytime I want.
It's fixable.
I swear.
I swear it's fixable.
Let's see.
All supports are just...
Someone's like, there's too much sustain in this game.
All supports are just really...
Their ults are just not creative.
Their ults are not creative for supports.
That's why.
I think like...
If the support ult has more diversity...
It would be more fun.
Am I the only one here?
What?
No!
Okay, I gotta reset the Doom matches.
Am I gonna be in the same lobby?
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
Loki ult?
No, it's Mantis, Luna, and...
Sue.
It's just all...
It does the same thing.
That's it.
It all does the same thing.
So I don't find it that creative.
It's just the support ult that makes you...
This makes you too...
Too vulnerable for stuff.
Oh, Cloak and Dagger, yeah.
Cloak and Dagger, Sue, Luna, Mantis all does the same thing as their support ult.
And it's just...
That's why there's just so much sustainability.
If there was more diversity in support ults, then like...
Uh...
Then like...
Then there's...
Oh.
Okay, I'm so bad in Groot.
I'm so bad in Groot.
Oh yeah, all the people in here watching me.
I hope you enjoyed the stream, guys.
If you guys like my content, please check me out on YouTube.
I usually stream on YouTube.
Whoa.
Oh, he's a liar.
He said he only plays.
Wait, he's a fucking liar.
He says I only he- Oh wait, no, this guy only hellos.
Hmm.
Well, guys.
Who- Who do I clone?
I have to be on Luna duty, apparently.
Who do I clone?
I clone Jeff.
Ah!
Oh no, we have toxic teammate?
I must mute.
Oh fuck, okay, whatever.
I'm turbo-trolling on Shark.
You know what, this actually works.
You don't do that.
Let's see.
This is abusive language to me.
This language is already abusive.
It's abusing my elo.
I believe we already- There's no way we already have someone that's gonna throw.
I mean, we got a human- Wait, we have a human, Torch?
But you gotta kill, though.
Can't be throwing, right?
But you gotta kill.
Right, guys?
Yeah.
Wait, this is- No, I should just- I forgot.
Never, never give up hope.
Never give up hope.
Remember the last time you started hoping, Doki?
Remember that?
I don't-
Remember how that was like for you?
Hope will only disappoint.
Oh, they have a Hawkeye.
I don't wanna- I really don't wanna- Holy shit.
Okay, I legitimately think he needs to stop playing this thing.
He's actually trolling on that character.
Like, if you're stuck in Celestia and you're playing the thing, it's not the character.
He's actually- Cause that character- The thing is like one of the easiest- One of the easiest tanks to play right now.
But you can also not solo tank him.
It might be easy, but you still can't solo tank.
I don't wanna use my ult because- Okay, now I can.
That makes sense to use it.
You wanna kill our Jett?
I don't know why you would wanna kill him.
Okay.
Did he do it?
Why?!
Yes!
Remember, Jokey.
Don't- Never hope.
Never.
This is what I get for hoping.
This is what I get.
That's actually what I get for, like, believing in my team.
Oh, thank god he swapped off the thing.
Actually no, I wish he was still on the thing.
Then we- It'd be easier.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Yes, I died too now.
I did not realize they pushed up that far.
Silly Jokey.
You're hoping again.
So silly.
Remember what that was like?
You're so silly.
I mean, we practically just have a lot of DPS players.
Okay.
And a Jeff.
That's basically it.
Okay.
This is where we die.
We just have- We're like trickling in.
We're not even playing- Like our Bucky- Why?!
Why?!
We're not even playing together.
Okay.
See guys?
This is why I stopped hoping.
Hope is for losers.
It's all about the doom cues.
I like how we win another support and it's not another support ult.
Like...
That's my favorite part.
Okay.
Let me just stand.
Shit!
Okay.
I'm okay.
Where's my mag?
Okay.
Oh shit.
Wait.
It's okay guys.
I don't know where he's going but it's- Eat the-
How did they all not die?!
Okay.
That's fine.
We can fight this for two more minutes.
I believe.
It's okay.
Okay.
I need to reload so I'm trying to believe- I still believe.
Oh!
The Star Lord tried to fly up!
That- Oh that's not a kill barrier?
Oh.
That's why.
Okay.
That makes more sense now.
The shark also thought that was a kill barrier.
That makes a lot more sense.
That's funny.
We both thought the same thing, little guy.
Alright.
Aww.
They're running double tank now?
Maybe we stay up here.
Nevermind.
They're like- You know what?
Fuck both of these people.
In general.
You know what you're doing wrong?
You're heal botting too much.
That was my issue.
That's basically it.
A good support, also DPS.
And that's a thing that I need to do more too.
Like, you're supposed to balance between healing and DPS.
Because even when you heal too much, which is why I like- This is like something I need to learn as well.
If you heal too much, you're giving the enemy team a lot of ults too.
Oh my god!
I was so close!
I'm so sad.
And I don't get the rez?!
Aww.
The fuck, he had to die first.
Oh, okay.
We're still winnable.
Fly!
Come on, everyone!
Yes!
There we go.
Too much hope.
Guys, I don't know if we can push it all the way.
Yes!
Oh, if our Bucky can get that kill, maybe?
Nice.
He's opening a portal.
Maybe we can...
No, we can't.
I need to...
We need to go back here.
Come back!
I'm back, though!
I'm back!
I came back!
I was there!
I don't know about my teammates, but I came back, at least.
I did it!
I came back.
Two other people didn't.
Come back.
It's okay.
It is what it is.
That guy was so sad.
He was so sad!
Alright.
I guess another way to climb in support is just by calming.
For the support, most supports just have to micro and macro the fucking team.
I'm not calming because, like, it's 4... it's almost 5 AM.
5... I don't think there's anything to save 5 AM players.
You know what I mean?
I don't think talking is gonna save them.
I...
Let's just end it.
I know.
If it was, like, primetime, then maybe.
But, like, this is not primetime at all.
Oh yeah, that was a mistake from these guys.
Oh, that was a mis... Wait, they went Panther?!
Oh, shit.
Okay, I was not expecting that.
That Panther pick was very clutch for them.
Literally, they won because of it.
We all grouped up.
I didn't know they were on Panther.
Froze somebody?!
Oh, shit.
I froze their fucking Sue from 20 miles away.
Trying not to be grouped up.
Knowing that they have a Panther, I can't be grouped up.
Because that just gives so many resets.
The only thing that sucks is that...
Yeah, see?
I didn't group up.
Hey, nice.
We can go up now.
Go!
Yay!
Disappear!
Oh, not yet!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he didn't charge it!
They fucking beat him up.
Beat him up.
That's right.
Fucking beat him up.
Oh my god.
He actually... He slam dunked my face.
I was so dead, but he didn't charge it.
He did not charge it whatsoever.
That actually saved me.
He got impatient.
He actually got impatient with it.
Thank god.
Hello, goodbye.
Yeah, and then you saw my Magneto bubble at one second after I get fucking dunked on?
Yeah, I saw that.
Aww, he fucking dunked it too early too.
That separates a Magneto player when a Magneto player is like, impatient.
That's unfortunate.
You got this.
You got this, Hawkeye!
Aww, they're running low-key.
I wish I could copy actual characters.
Goodbye.
I'm predicting where he is by looking at the shadows.
Look at that.
I touched everything.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, nice.
Oh, what?!
The freeze came out!
Okay, that freeze came out, guys.
That's actually bullshit.
The freeze actually came out of my hand.
I think it's just ping.
The 70, the actual ping diff hit me there.
I...
I literally saw the fucking snowflake comes out.
And it didn't work.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe it.
Oh my god.
The world is cruel.
Hawkeye, please, don't hide from me.
Oh my...
Okay, everybody, we all want heals, I know.
Okay.
That Magneto really fucking hates me.
He really does.
He definitely does not like me at all.
Good aim.
He hit a wall.
It was very interesting to watch.
Yeah, he...
He really wanted me dead, that's for sure.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
That's very unfortunate for that guy.
If only I had something to heal for that snowflake.
Alright.
Oh, shit!
Okay, I did not expect him to push up.
Alright.
It's fine.
Things are...
Oh.
Oh, people are crashing out.
It's fine.
People...
Don't you love it when your team's crashing out?
Love it.
Some games are literally just GG's by character select.
Pretty interesting.
Oh, cool.
It's fine, he's dead though.
No, I knew this game was...
I knew...
There's a reason why I didn't hope because...
They were already crashing out...
On character select.
So I was like...
I knew that this team...
Was not...
There was no hope for this team.
And there was no...
Also thing usually at these hours...
Is the DPS character...
DPS players that are...
That are on at this time.
There is a surprising abundance of DPS players that crash out at this time.
Apparently.
He...
Is he still trying to...
Oh, he got me.
He got me.
The first...
The first slam dunk of the day.
Naiko, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Peters, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
That game was 100% rigged from the start.
That...
He finally got me.
Wow, you guys are...
You got it.
Alright, who was the worst player?
Oh yeah, this guy was the first crash out.
Who was the first crash out?
This guy, right?
Alright.
This guy crashed out first.
Who was the second crash outer?
MrBrokenBot.
Thank you for the five gifted stars.
Thank you, thank you.
The comeback guy was...
Comeback!
That was a rocket, this guy.
This guy was funny.
Comeback!
Oh, but he was doing really well as...
As...
Hawkeye.
Yeah, he was like...
He was like...
Let's see.
Who was it?
Who was arguing?
I wish I know what numbers were.
What the numbers were.
No, this guy was the one that says I only had a...
And then he swapped a group.
Burrito, thank you for the 300 biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, let's know what you did.
We know you...
No, I don't know what you're talking about.
You know what's funny?
I played Rocket for one...
For like...
The first point.
And then I got instantly flamed.
And I knew I was not the problem there.
I was like...
Just my...
See, this is what happens.
Just your presence as Rocket triggers...
A fucking fight or flight response.
Because of how hated he is.
I was like...
Okay.
I know Rocket's bad.
But I did not...
I played for one point and got...
And I got yelled at.
And then the entire team...
Was like...
That Rocket was not the problem.
And then they all...
Piled on to the Luna player.
Because the Luna was like...
This is the Rocket's fault.
And then my entire team was like...
Okay.
That is not the Rocket's fault.
And they instantly flamed our Luna.
It was crazy.
They actually flamed her.
I was like...
Oh my god.
I was not ready for that.
I don't think people know...
That Rocket is actually...
Meta in higher elo now.
Or in competitive.
People actually play Rocket in competitive.
Because he's actually really, really good.
And people don't know that.
Thank fucking god.
I'm so happy.
Only with Punisher?
No, it's not just Punisher.
It's because of Bucky.
It's not Punisher.
It's Bucky.
Because Bucky is so fucking strong now.
And one above all.
In the top elo.
That people actually willingly have to play Rocket.
And his Rez is just really good now.
It's his Rez and Bucky team up.
Because Bucky is such a good character now.
That in competitive.
In like esports.
A lot of people run...
In esports.
Oh my god.
Celestia 3.
Where are you?
Oh my god.
I've never...
It's been so long since I've played these lobbies.
I...
At these hours?
What is it gonna be like?
What is it gonna be like at these...
At these hours?
Someone's level 87 Celestia?
Celestia?
I wish I could see that.
I'm banning.
Oh.
Oh fuck.
Sorry.
I didn't see you are on Groot.
I just hate playing against Groot.
Alright.
See, I apologize.
I'm a nice person.
Alright.
I'm banning Luna.
Fuck it.
Usually is a good time.
Not 5 in the...
Not 5 in the morning.
Hey, bad Loki!
Life is terrible.
I guess I'll play Sue.
I...
Just...
Just wanted to play Sue.
I just wanted to play Loki.
I just wanted to...
I can't believe it.
Why is life so cruel?
Dang it.
Okay.
What's my...
Record?
I don't even know what my current record is at the moment.
I think I'm like win-loss, win-loss, win-loss.
The fucking cycle.
Alright.
Are we...
Okay.
Okay, Groot thing.
Okay, that is...
Interesting.
We don't have a...
We don't have...
Nah.
Nah, there's no point.
I might as well play Sue for this.
There's no point.
At least we get variety in this ELO.
You have to watch the 30th time I play Duna.
I'm actually playing other characters.
Variety.
And support.
And if you were like...
Support is support.
What variety?
You heal.
Look, this is as much variety as you can get.
There are other characters besides...
I know, it's actually crazy.
The support variety.
Alright.
We should not be playing this support lineup for...
Oh, I didn't pull them in.
He shielded that.
That was unlucky.
Oh, I don't have pull.
I spammed my thing too much there.
We can kill him, right?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
There's no way we don't kill him.
There we go.
Get back in here.
Get back in here!
Get your ass in here!
Nice.
I literally turned around.
How are we still...
Okay, I was gonna say.
He went...
Hey, you did say get back.
Okay, I...
It was figuratively.
I did not mean literally come back.
I thought it was just a funny haha.
You ult first, Mantis.
They don't deserve me talking.
They don't deserve my vocals.
Dude.
Come back in 3-4 hours when it's not Degen hours then maybe.
Okay.
I used that jump for no reason.
Oh shit, I ult first.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Okay, I hope our...
Oh my god.
Hahaha.
Shit.
Maybe we can...
Our fucking...
Okay, he did not care.
Hahaha.
He...
Our fucking...
Jesus Christ, this fucking guy is actually...
annoying.
Doesn't help that...
There we go.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh shit.
Please guys.
Please, do not let me die.
I swear to god.
Okay.
I used my own thing.
Omega, thank you for 10 gifted souls.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, nice.
Oh wait, our Mantis got...
Okay, they can still touch.
Oh fuck.
Oh shit.
Don't stand still.
I see you.
I see...
I see you fucking...
I heard Mantis standing still...
and I had so much fear for him.
I was like, Mantis dude...
Hawkeye is coming.
Don't do it.
Oh, I didn't get him.
Don't wanna stand behind my...
Oh.
Maybe a little worried.
Maybe...
Yeah, sorry.
Definitely a little bit of worry right there for him.
That was my bad.
I was not aware of what you were...
of your plans there.
What the fuck?
Get this...
Get this fucker outta here.
Oh.
Okay, goodbye.
Good luck.
Don't worry, I'll disappear.
Don't worry.
We disappear.
What?
Where's our cart?
Oh no!
I couldn't ult that.
God damn it.
I couldn't ult it.
I'm so sad.
Dude, where's...
Yeah, I was like, where's the cart?
I mean, that was a cool ult, but like, where's the cart?
It's fine.
We have Mantis ult here.
I assume that...
He's had Mantis ult.
Okay.
I'm gonna stay behind this.
I'll stay...
I'll put this up there.
Don't worry.
We have shit.
It's fine.
It's not fine anymore.
Oh.
Okay, to be fair, I thought he...
I thought he ulted something.
Okay?
Like...
You would assume something gets ulted.
Okay, that's good.
They wasted the cloak ult.
There was no reason to use that.
That's good.
That's actually really good for us.
Where did my strange go?
Okay, wait.
I can...
I was gonna say I can do something cheeky right now.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
I wanted to do something cheeky, okay?
But then everybody's dead.
We did it, team.
We did it.
We were a little too slow.
But you did nothing.
We did it.
Wait.
Jokey, but you didn't do anything.
That's why we are a team.
We did it.
Look at that.
It's okay.
I showed them.
Guys, look at that wall you can break.
Okay, but that's a cool tech, okay?
As a Ms. Woman, I break the wall and then I pull them in.
My team's just killed everyone before I...
Like, what can I do when they kill everybody?
Guys.
It would've been too...
It would've been a great tech.
If my team just wasn't that...
If my team was not so good.
My team was just too good.
I'm so unfortunate that my team was just so good.
Yes.
Suffering from success, guys.
Oh my god.
It's so unfortunate.
I can't believe it.
My team was just too fucking good.
Team too good.
Sad.
Don't you hate it when you have good teammates that you can't show your stream content?
What's the point?
God.
Just the first world problems.
When you just...
Oh.
Lucky.
Okay.
Bye.
I try to pull them a little bit closer.
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
But don't worry.
That guy is just doing tickle damage right now.
It's fine.
Don't worry, I'm healing.
I'm just throwing it in a general direction.
Oh, I should not have wasted the pull.
I wasted a pull there.
Wait, did I break my...
Is my shield broke?
Oh, it is.
Don't worry.
That rock is gonna break and then people will know I was there.
Sorry, I meant tree.
Where's my team?
There you go.
What are you gonna do, huh?
Archer is dead.
Oh, wait.
He got rez.
That's what they're gonna do.
Shit.
That was scary.
Where's our Syla?
Syla, where are you?
Syla.
Where's my team?
Don't worry.
Oh, maybe worry a little bit because he definitely has ult.
I'm waking you up!
Wake up!
Okay, nice.
We're good.
God, Invisible Woman is pretty easy.
Now that I think about it.
Don't get hit!
That grid has ult.
That's fine.
I just jumped away.
Just jump away.
It's that easy.
Oh, wait.
Hey!
Astrange is back.
Oh my god.
Wait, Celestial lobbies are pretty easy.
Wait.
Wait, when you have confident teammates, that's crazy.
These guys don't- This Venom does not know how to play Venom.
He has to- He needs to stop.
He- He actually- This Venom does not know how to kill people.
Like, I have real trauma.
This guy does not give me trauma.
I- He does not- I have real trauma from good Venom players.
This guy is just, like, tickling me right now.
It's actually crazy.
He's just a little tickler.
Yeah, he's just farming ults.
He's just farming support ults for us.
You know what?
Get over here.
That's right.
Get your ass over here.
I ain't afraid.
I'm not.
I have 275 HP.
Oh, I'm not afraid of you either.
Get over here.
I hope we double support ult just to kill your ass.
Oh shit, wait.
That's okay, right?
That's my guy.
Let's go!
That's right.
I'm pro-lying this.
I'll beat your ass up.
Oh, great.
Let me help him.
Don't worry.
He's just a tickler.
You'll be fine.
Oh shit, wait.
People are dead.
Wait, people are dead.
Oh, I wish I had my ult.
I am so sorry.
Whoops.
Oh shit, let's go!
Oh shit.
Please.
Don't keep throwing.
It's okay.
My team is just too good.
My team did it.
We goofed around too much.
I should have saved my ult there.
But it's okay.
I knew my team could do it.
See?
I told you.
It's just that easy.
It's that...
I don't understand how the Star Lord and the Namor did not kill anybody.
See?
This is what I mean.
This is what I mean when I hate playing against a good group player.
I get plus 15?!
Oh my god.
That game was too easy.
Okay, I need to avoid the Venom though.
This person should not quit their day job.
This person needs to find a new main because that's not it.
This guy does not know how to actually play Venom.
I played against Andrew's Venom and like five other fucking Venom mains in high elo.
And like, I just...
You suffer.
You...
No one has fun.
No...
No one...
No one has fun.
It's just...
It's just rough out there.
And that Venom was like going to Weenie Hut Jr.
It definitely was just Weenie Hut Jr. Venom.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Oh, back to eternity lobbies.
Or half eternity lobbies.
That guy's mic was so fucked up.
Alright.
I ban Gru and I use Bathroom.
That's my job today.
I play lowkey.
I'll practice more.
My day is done when I ban lowkey.
I did it!
I got my Gru ban!
Oh, we don't have a tank player.
Oh...
Guys, it's my eternity game!
Come on!
It's my eternity game on my second account!
I don't care, honestly.
I think they care more about getting eternity than I do.
If we lose, we lose.
I didn't care more.
I'm just fucking around.
Okay, I'll do...
Doing a U ult first.
There we go.
Now if they double support ult me, it's not my fault.
I did my communication of the year.
Calm of the year.
You might get yours for a faster.
But alright.
I believe in this, Luna.
Don't worry, I'm learning lowkey.
I will not get mine first.
But they don't know that.
They don't know that.
I don't think I should give them zero confidence starting the game.
I don't know.
It's my team.
Oh no, there's Hawkeye.
Try not to look at them.
Oh no.
Hey, come down!
Not like that.
That's unfortunate for him.
Please stay on the ground so I can splash damage you.
Please.
That's all I want.
If you stay on the ground, I can use splash damage.
And then it would be so much easier for me.
Please.
I just need splash damage.
Okay, nice.
They just let us have that for free?
What am I- We're- Where is- Am I- They actually- Oh my god.
These-
Actual lobbies.
I don't think like anybody is alive anymore in these lobbies.
Talking of that.
Oh, I'm debating- Okay.
I'll use that so my team can at least back up.
Aggro it.
People are definitely not alive during these times.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Hey, nice.
Where's my- Okay, I got lost!
I was like- Okay, I'm gonna let this Luna- Okay, our Luna's not healed.
I was gonna say, I'm gonna let our Luna heal this.
So he can get his ult.
I'm lost in the song.
These Qs are- People who are definitely crashing at hard.
I refuse to believe this.
Okay, I'll put this up because- Alright.
Our Neymar does not look like he's okay right now.
Alright guys.
Hey guys.
You guys okay?
We dance!
Cause our Luna fell down now!
Yippee!
I run away now!
Unless!
Oh, I didn't have shift now!
I thought I had shift!
I was looking at my clothes!
It's okay!
Sorry, I thought I had shift.
But I was looking at the wrong cooldown.
I was looking at my clone cooldown.
I was like, wait, I have a shift!
And then for my shift, I was like, one second?
It's okay.
I just wanted him to, you know, feel good about himself, guys.
I just wanted him to feel good, guys.
Okay, he's having a rough day and I want to make sure he gets at least one kill.
Quenna, thank you for the one gift.
Thank you, thank you.
I appreciate it.
I bet you I'm gonna get plus 19 and I'll be one point away from- One point away.
Wait, why is everyone humping Luna?
What about me?
I'm Loki.
I'm Loki played by Tom Hiddleston!
Come on!
I'm everybody's dreamboat.
What happened?
You know what?
The Hiddles?
What about the Hiddleston?
I'm fucking the Hiddleston!
I'm British!
Well, I'm technically not British, but you know.
I'm Norse, but...
You know what?
There we go.
Wow!
Good luck, everybody.
Alright.
Okay.
I don't think we're winning this lobby.
Not winning this fight, for sure.
Shit.
Fuck.
I have to make sure.
I'd be surprised if...
Okay, there's three of us now.
We can make this work.
There's three of us.
Oh!
I thought we could make it work, okay?
I really...
I really thought it was possible.
I'm sorry.
I leave now.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Oh, I'm alive!
Please get on the ground so I can splash damage you.
Please...
Oh my god, I should not have given that Magneto a one.
I really shouldn't.
Okay.
Okay, it was my bad.
I gave him that one and I think we fucked up with that.
Okay, guys!
That's a lot!
That's a lot of health!
I don't know if that was worth it!
It's just two of them.
I'm fine.
Oh, it was not just two of them!
It wasn't just two of them!
Okay.
Maybe?
Guys, it definitely was not just two of them.
There's more than that.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, okay.
Oh no, I have to reload.
I'm so unfortunate!
That was so unfortunate.
Oh, man.
Guys, why did I give their Magneto that one?
That was a mistake.
Whoops.
That was actually a mistake.
Just the two of them.
There we go.
This is where I die, though.
This is absolutely where I die.
There it is.
Alright.
Maybe I shouldn't play Loki when we had someone that fucking flies.
Maybe!
Alright.
I gave that man too much confidence, guys.
I may or may not have fucked that up for us because of that.
I gave him that one kill and now their team is unstoppable.
Okay.
We have to go Luna because we have a Namor.
We not have a Yeti, but an Adam.
Okay.
I want to give it to our Namor if he's a flanking...
If he's a flanking Namor, then I should go on him.
But, I don't know.
Is our Star Lord or a flanking Namor?
That's true.
They shouldn't pick something that flies when I pick.
That is so true.
Also, like, who was it that was on Storm?
Who was the Storm player?
The Storm-Torch combo was not it.
It was wasting too much... too many ults for, like, one fight.
Guys, why did I give him that one kill?
I fucked up.
Actually, I'm gonna...
Oh my god, I really want to give it to our Namor.
I was pocketing...
The worst part was that I was pocketing the shit out of him too.
There was, like, nothing.
There was no way.
I don't know how else I could, like, clutch this for him.
Okay, I need heal.
Oh my god.
I love these so much.
Welcome to 5AMQs, everybody.
Truly a very special time on me.
This is basically every game, I think, at these hours.
I refuse to believe games are ever normal at these times.
Oh my god.
That's why I was like, it's always interesting to see who the players...
What kind of players play at these times.
Do I die?
She doesn't.
It's alright.
I saved you.
I'm a hero.
I think I might have saved the wrong person.
Now we don't have a king.
Oh my god.
They have strange ults.
Guys.
Woo.
I know, our Lemur is definitely flanker, though.
It's always interesting to see who the gamers are at these times.
Because, like, they're doing it out of their own free will, you know?
So it's like...
It's like, what is it like for these people to willingly play at these hours?
What is it like?
What is that like for them?
Okay.
Like, especially with so much hate in your system, too.
There was so much hate for that guy.
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna win.
Guys, I think I fucked up by letting that Mag have that one kill.
That... that might have been a mistake.
Maybe.
That strange ult.
That strange ult, so we'll see how it goes.
Okay, that's like...
Oh shit.
There we go.
That was a lot of ults, guys.
For the fact that we still have to kill this Magneto.
I mean, sure, I'm at 80%.
Okay, I... I have to go.
I have to... I don't know, I'm worried for my team.
I wanna play here, but I'm actually worried for my team.
Please, please.
Oh my god!
That was so close.
Okay.
That's... I just need to keep my tank up.
Yippee!
Please.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
We keep each other up?
If we keep each other up, then maybe?
Oh, this is...
Oh, hey!
Wow, we did it.
Yay!
Crash unavoided!
Yippee!
Plus 19, I can feel it.
That match felt like a plus 19... No, guys.
That felt like a plus 19 game.
That's...
That...
That does not feel like a plus 20.
I felt it.
I was like, there's no way this game would just hand it over.
There's no way.
There's no way this game would be like, you deserve 20 points after that.
Yeah!
Oh, I love that.
The classic.
The fucking classic.
Just one point.
I'm ready for the minus 29 right there.
There's final hits.
I like how he's like, you go, Human Torch.
He literally has seven final hits.
He was more like a damage farmer.
He was farming damage for the team.
That one death.
Every death I had, they took away.
They took it away from me.
They're like, you had that one death, we're not letting you have fun.
I was like, okay.
I guess, fuck me, right?
Alright.
Oh shit, that guy's a lowkey main.
What if I take his...
No lowkey for you.
You don't need it.
I need it for content.
Where's your content?
Medi, thank you for the 500 bitties.
No, we have four support players.
Can you be that...
Guys, we have four support players.
I am not going DPS.
Guys, for that plus one point.
As long as they don't ban Adam, it should be fine.
I can play Adam.
No, we are not.
I'm going to make them play tank DPS.
Fuck this.
Wait.
I was like, who are you going to copy?
Oh man.
Who the fuck are you going to copy, buddy?
No way.
Alright.
Let me do this.
Then we have triple rez.
No lowkey for you.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
We can run this then.
There we go.
I was going to be like, you know.
I am not playing DPS.
Guys, I am.
If I'm going to lose, we're not losing.
Alright.
Guys, the support players are finally waking up, guys.
Because it's 8am.
Apparently, some support players actually have decent schedules.
Oh my god.
Support players are waking up now.
They're support players on the lobby.
They're healthy and support.
They get breakfast and they're like, you know what?
Let me play some...
How did I miss that?
Some Marble Rivals.
To start the day off.
Is that healthy though?
To start the day off with some Marble Rivals.
Jesus Christ, everybody is taking so much damage.
Oh, it's because there's a Hella to my right side.
Guys, I don't know why we run triple support like this.
Alright.
Okay.
I don't know.
Let's see.
Alright.
Oh, we're running.
Yeah, but they're...
They don't have...
Oh wait.
This guy's one.
Come on.
Let's do this.
I didn't want to, but...
I don't have heal.
Sorry, buddy.
I thought I...
I thought I gave you...
Gave you a support...
A chain too.
Yeah.
I don't know.
They're running Mantis Starlord because I'm on Adam.
But like, I don't know about this.
We're dying to...
Oh, I forgot.
That guy's a Hawkeye player too.
That guy was a pretty decent Hawkeye player.
Guys, I have Rez.
I know like...
The thing is, lower healers don't know how to deal with Hawkeye.
Because people don't position themselves.
They like, position themselves in a way that benefits.
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, if I didn't have to reload, I'd kill him.
I'd actually kill him if I didn't have to reload.
Yeah.
I want to play up here.
But like, I don't know.
I failed it for the Rez.
But I don't know.
I feel like I might die.
I had to Rez that.
Just for the fact that...
Hey, welcome back.
Guys!
Really?
Okay.
You can tell that I don't get picked by the Hawkeye as much?
Because like...
Playing against a Hawkeye is all about positioning.
If you don't position well enough, you...
I'm on it.
I literally spawn on it.
It's literally positioning.
I know they have a Hawkeye, so I don't...
I position myself in a way where I don't get picked easily by Hawkeye.
And that's why Hawkeye is really, really good against lower ELOs because it's all about punishing positioning.
And you don't see it in like...
You don't see it in the higher rank lobbies because it's so easy to punish Hawkeye players.
Instead of playing Hawkeye, people just play Widow.
Because Widow is really...
Widow with a Mantis, with a good Widow player, is really, really good.
If you can hit headshots, you might as well just play Widow with a Mantis.
Or Bucky.
But Hawkeye is literally...
Oh, that's Mute Q7?
Uh-oh.
I don't really want to play.
Yeah, I'm gonna swap to Loki.
Not playing it.
I don't think it's...
It's not worth it.
Like, our Mantis is getting picked because of...
Anyone that gets picked right now...
Or I could be.
The Hawkeye is such good at punishing at poor positioning.
Might have to use that because my team needs heals.
Oh my god.
Everybody needs heals!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, everybody just needs heals!
Okay.
Where is...
I literally just got it.
Oh, that's a lie, but...
Okay.
Oh no.
Oh.
There we go.
Did we get the point?
What's the difference between Hawkeye and Widow?
Widow, like, Mantis...
Mantis buff.
Headshots instantly.
And it's easier to aim.
Her ult is even better than Hawkeye's ult, too.
What?
Spy.
Just wanted it to be there, so...
There we go.
Come on, get him!
Get him!
Okay, now I can position my clones, actually.
I want to position my clones in actual places.
Okay.
Oh no.
Okay, there we go.
I want to make it...
Okay!
Buddy!
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Please.
I have to fucking...
I have to, like...
Oh.
Woah!
Come on, I believe in you!
Hello!
I believe in you!
Go, hello!
Go!
Okay.
Alright.
Woah, Captain America!
What you doing, buddy?
Oh!
That's unfortunate, buddy!
Yeah, he definitely has clobber.
Oh shit, okay.
Let's go.
I walk over now.
And then I go there.
Don't worry!
I dance!
Go do your thing!
Okay.
Oh, fuck!
What?!
Oh, that's so unlucky!
I did not realize he was there.
Oh shit, nice!
Let's go!
I still might die, though.
It's fine.
It's okay.
It's not... it might not be as okay.
It's not okay.
I didn't have...
I couldn't TP to the other clone.
Oh my...
It's not over yet!
I actually...
My first rez!
I got the rez off!
We have one fight left.
Bro, people play this game...
Nah, I don't think he'd realize that.
Oh shit!
That's unlucky for him.
It's okay.
That's my bad.
That's actually my bad.
I pressed my shit, but it didn't...
What?!
That thing hit his head!
I was like, where was he?
I was like, wait, what?
He shot through the thing!
I could not see him!
That was a really good shot.
That's a really...
Yeah, he actually shot through the thing too.
What's going on?
I was about to press shift.
That's so rough.
That's actually rough.
Wait, I'm gonna...
This guy's a much bigger Loki player, because he's...
We just didn't have a tank players.
Um, I should avoid one of the supports, so I don't have that happen again.
Oh!
That minus 23!
I need to be in an eternity game to get 25!
I've been in too many Celestial games.
Oh!
That's rough.
That's like even rough.
Why?
Oh my god.
What is my luck there?
Why?
Why couldn't it give me an actual...
Why couldn't it...
I literally just needed plus 20.
Just like a crumb.
A fucking crumb.
I don't...
I guess I don't deserve it.
I just don't deserve it.
I wasn't...
I didn't beg hard enough.
I only died to him like twice.
No, my positioning as that Luna was bad.
Like I...
Usually I would never frontline that hard as Luna with the ult.
But I also thought he was dead.
I thought...
I didn't realize he was still alive.
And in the second one, I literally didn't see...
I was walking to the point.
I think if I could press my shift in time, I would have got it.
That one...
The second time I died wasn't positioning.
We literally had to get to point.
Like there was nothing we could do there.
Cause it was literally like we had to get to point or we lose it.
Oh my god, that was so bad from my end.
That was actually so...
I was not aiming there.
He doesn't know where I am though.
Woah.
Where am I?
Oh, what kind of fight are they having up there?
My kill.
Yoink.
I hate that skin.
It's so annoying.
It looks great, but that skin is so annoying when you're playing it.
Cause every...
Every shot is just...
Like guitar.
Like it's just...
I hate that the skin has special sound effects.
Cause the special sound effects are so distracting.
Do I play DPS?
Cause it's fun.
I just can't play it in Eternity level.
You have to admit, DPS is fun.
I'm just not good enough for it.
And you don't want to play...
You don't want to watch me play DPS in fucking Doom.
In like Doom queues.
They...
I don't know.
Those sound effects are so obnoxious when you're playing Spider-Man.
I just think that...
I don't like the low-key...
That low-key...
Was it the Demon Lord skin or whatever?
There's nobody here.
I leave this one in every queue.
But like, they have like...
What was it?
It's for like...
I think the ones I hate is...
Where is low-key?
This one?
I don't like...
I don't like this skin's...
The Butcher skin.
When he does the echo sound when he talks.
Cause it's really annoying.
And the Spider-Man one.
And the Luna one.
I hate...
I hate the sound effects for this one.
It's too loud.
For like being competitive, I'm just not used to it.
It's way too loud.
I feel like the sound balancing for them is not as like...
It's not the same as the default.
And then also the Spider-Man one.
I don't like it.
This one is so annoying.
Every little fucking flick you do is a sound effect.
Yeah, I'm too much of a nerd.
I'm too much of a nerd when it comes to like...
Competitive.
I just don't like...
I just don't like it.
It's just too annoying.
Oh, this one has a lot of players.
How long have I been streaming so far, chat?
Are they roleplaying?
Are they roleplayers?
Oh, they are definitely not roleplaying.
Look at him go.
Look at the Wolverine just running away.
It's just like...
He's just running away.
He's like, nope.
Oh, come on.
Like...
Where did he go?
That's my kill.
Doesn't matter.
I think her default skin is the best one.
No, I agree.
That's why...
I think all her skins so far are really ugly.
IMO.
I'm not a huge fan of their skins.
I don't like...
What?!
Oh, just cause you're married.
Just...
That's not fair.
Actual marriage diff right there.
I was like, what?
Wait, they are roleplaying.
Oh my god.
I mean, they've been here for...
These are like actual...
These are regular roleplay lobbies.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm ruining this roleplay.
That's right.
No roleplay for you.
Wait, where did you come from?
Oh.
No roleplay for you.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
No roleplay.
Whoa, where did I go?
Oh, he's lucky.
Oh, no.
I'm not lucky.
Oh my god.
I wasn't lucky there.
No, no, no.
He fixed his ult.
He actually fucked up his ult there.
Poor guy.
It's roleplay, Spiderman dies.
Really?
That's sad.
You're a rocket.
You're a little guy.
You're just a little guy.
How are Qs so long?
Are Qs that long in the morning?
If your wife comes over.
If your wife comes over, you know what I'm gonna do.
That's fucking right.
I'll kill both.
I have ult.
I can kill both of you.
You know what I hope rivals have in the future?
Custom lobbies where you can customize.
Custom lobbies like Overwatch.
Then people will do those chill or kill lobbies.
People are using Doom Qs, Doom lobbies as the actual chill or kick lobbies.
And then people actually are just like...
Eat dating.
I think...
I've seen the ones that were like...
18 plus mic only.
Mercy player looking for E-boy.
The titles are like...
Yeah!
If you open up Overwatch 2 right now, you'll find that...
Exact lobby.
Not the exact naming.
But 70 variations of that name.
I remember when I had time.
You know, when I actually had a life.
It was funny to see like...
Whoa, that's cool.
That's five.
I went into one of them and just sat there and listened to the conversation.
Because I was curious as to like...
What do they talk about, you know?
Like, what do they talk about?
In these lobbies.
And it's very interesting.
And some people apparently...
Because some people know each other.
And they'll be like...
Oh yeah, I saw you in that other lobby the other day.
In the other chill lobby.
And that's what they do every day.
All they do is just...
Is just sit in those...
They just open up Overwatch and sit in those lobbies.
To have conversations.
But they don't play the game.
They don't play Overwatch.
It's like their social interaction for the day.
You know how people boot up VRChat to talk to people?
I'm fucking... I wanna ban Groot.
There's no way.
Not the 25er.
There's...
Oh my god.
The 25er.
They are playing...
No, they are playing a different game.
I'm not going Luna for the fucker that did not ban...
That didn't ban...
I'm not going Luna for the fucker that did not ban Groot.
You have hope someone else goes Luna.
You're not getting the Luna team up.
You fucker.
That's right.
I don't care enough to give you Luna.
I wanted...
I wanted the fucking Groot ban.
Give me Groot ban now.
It's the namer.
Like, Magneto does nothing for him.
He can block the Magneto with his fucking bubble.
What are you afraid of?
What are you afraid of, you fucking coward?
Look at me in the face.
What are you afraid of?
That moment that name gets on streamer mode, I'm looking you up.
Alright, let's go.
We have Penny Venom.
This is not it, but it's okay.
It's low elo.
Anything can work.
Honestly, no.
Like, you don't have to worry about playing meta until you get to...
Until you get to, like, Eternity 200.
Like, anything can...
Unless you have...
Unless you have, like...
There you go.
Unless you have a really good one trick player.
Like, I know so many really good...
What the...
It, like, instantly destroyed.
Got destroyed.
That's crazy.
Jesus Christ.
I'm just trying...
Nice.
Get on the point.
I got...
That's actually crazy.
I was getting instantly destroyed.
Yay!
Vortex Fields!
There you go.
You get that.
I'm saving my push for the Panther.
If he's still there.
There you go.
Couldn't get that away.
Woo!
Goodbye!
Goodbye.
That's a little embarrassing for you.
Oh, this is bad.
Okay.
It's not bad anymore.
I don't have push, though, for our Luna.
But that's okay.
I don't need push.
I say it before I die.
It's okay.
I don't need push, guys.
Maybe he'll be over there.
Nice.
Oh, no.
Not the guy.
Wait.
Okay, nice.
We have this.
I don't know what's going on in there.
I'm out of ult.
Hope you guys are having a fun time.
Oh, there you go.
My orb's gone.
Nice.
Kill that one guy.
Yeah!
Oh!
No!
Oh, he got...
He got...
Let's just fight on point.
I'm coming back.
I'm running.
I'll be there soon.
I'm almost there.
I'm running.
Don't worry.
Get on point.
I had no idea how the fuck...
We can win this.
Yeah, I'm not using ult.
There's no reason to.
What?
Where did he go?
Okay.
Where'd he go?
Nice.
Easy.
Okay, I right...
I...
I ult first.
Okay.
There we go.
My...
My calm of the year.
It's surprising how much that actually helps out.
Strange, thank you for the five gifted ships!
Oh, subs.
Sorry.
Fuck, I'm not on YouTube.
I'm not on YouTube.
I'm on Twitch.
Five gifted subs!
Thank you!
Akira, thank you for the tier one sub for two months!
Alright.
Yippee!
What the fuck are these names?
Ayo, we were just in doom.
Wait, who?
You talking about me?
Or...
Who?
Me?
John King Kong?
Yes, the Asylum.
Oh, they are...
Oh, they were both roleplaying.
Whoa!
The Penny and the...
The Hella.
Alone in the roleplay room.
Bringing them back.
Put...
They should bring it back.
Just for...
Just for Marble Rivals.
I wish they would do that.
Oh, Moonlight.
I haven't seen a fucking Moonlight in years.
But obviously, like, any ELO...
You don't need to play meta in this ELO.
I mean, it's helpful, but like...
This is a wild, wild west.
What are you doing?
What's your plan?
What was your plan, buddy?
What was...
Actual, what was your plan?
That was interesting.
Whoa!
Going back here.
Going here.
Oh no.
Yes, he is.
All I have to do is just knock in Agumoto.
That's basically it.
Oh, I hope he doesn't follow me.
Oh.
There we go.
Guys, I think the strange ass started to disassociate.
He is not playing the game anymore.
He is absolutely...
I don't know if you noticed it, but I don't think the strange is, like, actually playing...
Oh, what?
Get out.
Get out of here.
There we go.
Oh.
That is not alright.
I don't...
Oh.
Unlucky.
Strange, please, what are you doing, strange?
He is not playing the game.
I'm avoiding him.
I...
He is absolutely not playing the game anymore.
Yeah.
That...
That strange...
He should refund his skin.
He should refund his skin and never play again.
Play strange again.
It's not made for him.
100%.
It is absolutely not made for him.
Don't worry, I got you.
Stand behind me.
Oh.
What?
Oh, shit.
Oh, nice.
There you go.
I wish you could.
He's a lord.
He's a lord?
There's no way.
He's a lord.
Oh, look at that, plus 19.
Look at that.
I have to avoid him.
That was not...
That was not ideal to watch at all.
Alright.
Am I MVP?
Oh, look, that was me.
What did I do?
I guess I did pretty alright.
Oh, my god.
We all saw what he was doing, right?
On Strange.
He was not a functioning person.
He was absolutely not functioning at all.
Alright, back in the mines I go.
Yeah, that's the best part.
I wish they gave us more exploit slots.
Like, you have to stack so you can get more...
Whoa!
Not cool, buddy.
Wait, what?
That hit me?
Not cool.
Whoa.
What?
Taquito?
What the fuck?
What?
Question mark?
Oh, my god.
Playing...
Playing tank in...
Playing tank in Doom matches is like...
It's just like Overwatch.
Like, why?
How do you enjoy this?
Like, I don't understand.
Me big.
Me throw punch big.
He just wants to be a big man.
Puny Sylar.
Like, I think we'll get him just...
Don't worry, we'll double team him.
Don't worry.
We'll kill him together.
We shall unite together.
Let's go.
We did it.
Oh, goodbye.
Okay, but like...
Oh, my god.
What is my RNG of that ult?
The RNG for that ult.
Fuck you.
You're not...
Thank god I know where the health pack is.
You're not getting that health pack.
I refuse to let you get that health pack.
That's what I hate.
Sometimes these Psylocke RNG is so stupid.
Alright, either I get this or like...
I just...
It's GG on character select.
Who is not loaded in?
Who is my guy that's not loaded in?
Mr8.
MrLevel76.
That's level 8.
Wait, okay.
Let's see how many...
Oh, I was gonna say...
Are there any ult account players too?
Oh, okay.
Oh, he plays everything.
I wanna Loki.
You go play other support.
I Loki.
Rude.
Oh my god, people are talking.
It's 7am...
It's 9am.
Get Groot out of here.
Get him out of here!
Get him out!
Why?!
Now let me pick!
Doesn't matter!
Fucking hate that character.
This character fucking sucks!
I swear, this guy...
Okay, there you go.
That was unfortunate.
That was so unfortunate for me.
Luna's open if any of you guys can.
No, Luna.
Oh, do you want it?
No.
No!
I don't like how people call him strategist.
Just call him support.
It's a fucking support character.
Don't...
We don't need to be fancy here.
Yeah, I'm a Vanguard player.
Tink!
It's Tink!
Yeah.
I'm a Vanguard.
Why?!
It's two syllables!
Tink is one!
True Vanguard is free.
Nerd!
It's more Chuni like that.
It's DPS.
DPS sounds cooler than fucking duelist.
Okay.
I don't know if that's where you put it.
I'm learning.
Guys, I'm learning, guys.
Clearly it was not...
Not...
Clearly it wasn't.
Alright, I'm on their Luna right now.
Oh, it's okay.
It's not okay.
It's okay, but I guess we're not gonna...
Their Venom is here.
How do you know?
On the card?
I'm trying.
I am reloading.
Jesus Christ, there's so many.
Okay.
I have to use this whenever we get flamed.
It's Starlord Hydra.
Oh, Luna's one, Luna's one.
Oh my god, the reload, please!
Okay, nice.
Get this Loki.
It's fine.
It's fine, I still have my clones.
I still have both clones, it's fine.
It's fine.
What was my HP?
What?
My HP was full!
What was my HP?
I swear to god, my HP was full.
It was...
It was full!
I saw it!
I was like, so healthy!
And then I was not?!
Oh my god!
Loki first.
Maybe Loki can do it.
There we go.
Okay.
Where is he?
Where was he?
Okay.
I was like, I'm so healthy!
I felt so healthy.
I really did felt so healthy.
I really did.
Oh my god, where am I?
Woah!
Where did I go?
Oh, what?
Okay.
Okay, this would be very awkward when...
I'm alive!
Oh, thank god I had that!
Wait.
Oh, I can't block.
It's okay, I'm okay though.
Is there a Loki right here?
It's fine.
I'm shooting the ground, it's okay.
I'm doing the strat and shooting the ground.
Oh, I couldn't.
I had to reload.
My bad.
I had to reload, my bad.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
No!
Quick, swap to Strange at touch point!
Quick!
Oh, nobody wanted to.
I was trying to press Q onto them.
Sorry, I just reset.
We could have swapped to Strange.
Strange, I pressed Q!
What?
It's not.
Fuck me, I guess.
Wait, what?
There you go.
I have to use that.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I couldn't get out of that.
Okay, we just gotta reset.
I couldn't get out.
I couldn't get out!
What happened there, man?
I don't know.
Oh, they're running Trip Support.
That's what happened.
What do you mean?
They ran Trip Support.
They need the crutch.
Okay, I need to copy Luna.
Okay, we swapped up.
Okay.
I blocked it.
Okay, let's go.
Wait, what?
Nice.
Okay.
Yippee!
I dance, I dance.
Oh, I didn't have...
Yep.
That's life.
Welcome to life.
I want Invis.
He can die.
That's just life.
Welcome to life.
What?
It is what it is.
One more shot.
No, you're not.
I'm aiming the ground.
Namor's right back in there.
Don't laugh!
Don't laugh or you die!
I'm on their support right now.
They're warmed.
Okay.
Don't laugh or you die.
Don't let it happen to you.
But it was pretty funny, you have to admit.
Oh my god!
I'm alive!
Alright.
Okay.
There you go.
Nice.
I'm trapped!
Look, that Venom was like, I got you now!
I'm like, now you see me, now you don't.
That's unlucky for the Venom.
That's very unlucky.
Woah!
I feel like the Namor was pretty good.
Alright.
Fizzbowl!
Thank you for the 100 bitties!
Thank you, thank you!
These games have definitely been interesting, but it's still fun watching you play.
I hope the games aren't as rough from here on out.
Alright, we win this.
I'm calling it.
We get our eternity back on this account and then it's...
I streamed longer than I was going to anyway.
And games have been alright.
It's more fun on the ult because like, I don't have to worry too much.
Especially if I'm soloing.
If I solo, I'll just play on this account.
I'll do like one game on main and see how games are like.
I play like until I lose and like, you know, it's usually it's one game.
I don't know how, but like, my fucking record has been like, nearly been like, I lose on character select.
Like both times I've played on stream, I literally lose on character select.
It's actually crazy.
It's actually... like, it's not even me.
It's just, I get such bad RNG in general.
I'm getting rid of the clone.
Never have the clone out.
What the fuck is prodigy?
Oh my god, he's maybe a prodigy right now.
It's like they all wear afk.
What happened?
Well, our fucking widow is popping off.
I mean, don't get me wrong, I'm not mad at this.
Okay, our widow is fucking insane.
I'm fucking... I'm going.
There's their infinite right there.
I'm pocketing.
I want this pocket.
I'm going in.
He deserves it.
There we go.
You can still win.
You can hold the first one and still win.
There we go.
This is it.
Let's go.
No, we don't respect 1v1s.
We don't.
We don't respect it, I guess.
Okay.
Don't worry, I got you.
That mag just standing there.
GG boys.
Yep, we did it.
Guys, I need this win.
What a fast round.
I deserve this.
I played really well there, guys.
I think I did really well in general.
I'm learning lowkey, guys.
I'm actually figuring out how to play.
I think... Whoa, I'm up.
Nice.
I'm up.
Guys, look at that.
I'm up one game.
Let's fucking go.
We're so bad.
Oh my god, what was my history like?
It wasn't that bad.
Not that bad.
I've actually started winning, too.
It was here that got bad.
It was here and then I have a positive.
I just lost and it was like minus... Okay, I need to know.
Is that guy Smurf?
Okay, Prodigy.
Prodigy.
Where is he?
Is he queuing right now?
Oh, he's in queue.
Oh, I couldn't tell.
Okay, let me look at the banner then.
Let me see.
I just want to see if it's... Okay.
Level 31.
Yeah, he's Smurfing.
Yeah.
Level 31.
Yeah, that's not your real... That's not your real ELO.
Yeah.
Anyway, guys, that was fun.
That was really fun.
I had a great time streaming today.
Four hours.
Nine more hours to go.
Thank you everyone for coming.
If you are new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, so please check me out there and subscribe to me there if you enjoyed my content.
If you want to support me via other means, I do have merch coming out or is out, so let me show that real quick.
So I do have plushies right now.
There's one week left on plushies, guys.
One more week.
One last week before they're gone forever.
You do !plush, I believe.
You can still pre-order your plushies.
We have one week left, and after that, it's gone forever!
Whoa!
And then while I still have to chill, I usually tweet out whenever I'm streaming on Twitch, so please check me out there.
Check me on Twitter to know when I'm streaming on Twitch.
I usually do Twitch streams very spontaneous and like guerrilla streams and stuff.
So it's usually on there when I tweet it out, and I think that's everything I want to show now.
All right, guys, thank you everybody for coming.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get your blood flowing.
Any of you, except for me, head to bed, guys.
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!